three two all right and we are love the
last word with a Bacchus returns and we
have a special guest I believed normally
you know II sense we have we do these
elaborate intro sometimes kind of little
I love podcasts flavor for the last word
but this is family this is the screen
this is what we gain with this whale ham
scream but also known to you is one of
the big destiny content creators out
here huge fan of his content and he
always figures out ways to manipulate
this looking for the looking for that
one piece of texture the bunchy forgot
to put in scream that will scream what's
going on it I'm doing good guys thanks
so much for having me back today I'm
really excited I'm something so much fun
to stuff to talk about and absolutely
lots of good things so glad to have you
back sir been a little bit what have you
been up to well he's traveling a little
bit and went on a couple of vacations I
went to oh the type of life Wow well
it's yeah a little bit overdue I've
called this the summer of Wilhelm but
yeah and I actually went to the what is
it the not the Ozzfest tour but the
Warped Tour 20th anniversary which is
like the biggest festival I've never
gone to a festival tour before my wife
and I know that this year and there was
like 30,000 people there on the second
night like blink 182 and The Offspring
play was crazy
so that's what I've been up to and
traveling and doing some work when I can
you know trying to always find something
I enjoy the game you know when I can get
a chance to play I learn new exotic
questions
let's say you've been playing a lot
ladies you have been playing as much
well it's like I usually can get on you
know like I say Tuesday's are the day
that I try to play the most so usually
after reset I'll get on and in the
afternoon or later in the evening and
try to get at least four or five hours
and over the course of nice you know we
just to see you and usually it I try to
know what I want to do before I go in
otherwise I'll get lost in it at this
point there's so much stuff it's so much
man yeah I was like there's so much
going on to do so with you um well you
know nothing nothing too major
as far as life changes but I mean
looking forward in a couple of months to
the new expansion which look like it's
gonna be pretty awesome and trying to
see a movie every once in a while
filming you still Rocking
yeah trying to keep up you know nice
nice nice nice TV so it's like any other
stuff I don't have enough time to do any
of the stuff that I want to do anymore
it's ridiculous now it's uh I mean yeah
it's a very much first world problem but
I was like there's a lot of TV shoot
shows I'd love to watch there's quite a
few games I never like finished much
less hardly like stepped into right yeah
oh yeah that that too yeah it's like I I
was I think I was mentioning to you I
bought risk of rain to me I felt like a
trailer for I forget it maybe it was III
okay I try to remember exactly what it
was a big gaming expo of just like a
couple of months ago and it was like oh
this looks like such a fun little game
don't pick it up and my buddy and I
picked it up just to play it again I got
to play like two hours of it and I've
been meaning to go back to it but it's
like if I have time to play oh my god
I'll play some destiny you know see
there's some content I can get you know
while I'm playing feel like I'm doing
something else no the PAX East yeah so
yeah yeah it was the same thing with
that exact game too
I did pick it up it's not you know it's
kind of a little indie can a fun little
runaround shooter yeah I think of what
you would call the what else kinda
reminds me of like gauntlet yeah yeah
it's kind of like a sci-fi version I
can't think of a term of the damn game
mm like a rubber stopper that's like
it's like dead cells like it's like you
know go through you get a little farther
every time you can learn but you start
over fresh or I cannot think of a damn
word you nothing wait no it's not Souls
like no wow this is what you do terms if
you've ever been like listening to a
podcast me like how can you not think of
that word the specific word you should
know a lot of things if you're on the
moment and you blink completely so just
heads up that happens it's that moment
all three of us are there so it's even
like I'm not describing it well but it's
I think you are I just can't think of it
like all I can say is I think it reminds
you to get over the top minecraft the
kind of three it's different but you
know like blondie nyan yeah I gave up I
don't eat owl and I don't no no no at
some point I'll just like scream the
word out and then I'll know exactly what
it is oh well obviously you guys know we
have some destiny stuff to talk about
today we got some news about shadow keep
over the course of the past week we've
got some news on a nice style ice
stylized way to knock some of our
enemies out so we'll talk about those a
little bit we got a little armored
discussion coming to us and of course
the twelve little iron banner Governor
on the corner but before we get to the
Destiny talk we got to talk about some
other things that happen in the world
comic-con is going on right now so
wanted to touch on that a little bit
guys so what what if you guys seen from
comic-con let us piqued your interest I
know there's one we kind of briefly
touched on before to be one thing
anything you've seen so far kognito
light with my Comic Con coverage I've
been watching like specific geek things
but nothing like major major so I was
like literally looking
like my subs that's my life subscribe to
that uh he is like a big transformers
gasps oh no g1 toy school I saw Marvel
Ultimate Alliance which I'm playing and
um
they showed some characters and looked
really cool Cyclops coming I bought that
and then um but I've been kind of kind
of light so you guys don't have to
educate me on what you guys have been
seeing cuz I really haven't been you
know playing all salute to the Red Queen
of the frown
she said she's driving but wanted to say
hi and you guys have a blast a salute to
the Queen we need you in the realm of
the last word well thank you very much I
know it's like we had some travel things
but we will get you on here soon can't
wait to have you yes absolutely crushing
it is so low but yeah you guys have to
educate me man what's going on at
comic-con Oh before I forget I was like
before you take it all scream because
those like in the world of comic-con in
movies like I know a good amount but
you've got me usually destroyed on this
knowledge so on YouTube so I was you
know it's always like I know comic-con
is going on and when you see the big
trailer start yeah that's like there's
like that's that I'm talking about so
for me the big one and I'm gonna steal
it
top go maverick so you guys good oh yeah
I already know all the fields all the
fields I saw my time like going crazy I
see of course
big movie it should be awesome and
honestly this is another one of those
where like they have the camera shot in
the trailer where it's like hey what
crazy ridiculous thing has Tom Cruise
like done now well it was like okay so
stark it was a Mission Impossible fall
out and he's like flying the helicopter
and they've got the cameras in there and
it's like the solo shot and stuff like
that so then of course you know Top Gun
maverick you've got him like what the
side shot like in old school Top Gun
where it's like cool let me give me the
salute then I go and then it cuts to him
with a camera in his face in the cockpit
takes off of the aircraft carrier and
he's the one flying the
things so it looks like he knows how to
fly a jet and I was like of course he
does why wouldn't he but some maneuver
he does in the end does like I don't
know if it's one of those that he
actually got to do but oh man I can't
wait but like I don't care if like the
reviews are like there's movies the
worst movie ever I'm still going to go
see it in theaters probably an IMAX the
biggest green as possible because I
don't know now the only thing I was
wondering cuz I thought about Top Gun
has just got like a couple classic songs
I wonder if the soundtrack can live up
to the first one cuz I honestly don't
know if it can those songs are too like
classic and fitting that I don't know if
like whatever songs go with the new one
can't even hold up what you think scream
well you're dead elaborate I was a very
elaborate well he's about to set up big
breath big breath get it all out here we
go here we go read out quickly to well
it's a build on everything he just said
Kenny Loggins is coming back for the
music oh there is a major character who
is in the movie who didn't see in this
trailer I'm almost positive they're
saving him for trailer 2 too big of a
thing okay all the shots of all the
planes are 100% real whoa so there's
very little I don't think there's any
CGI so yes I would say if you're gonna
see a movie in IMAX this is gonna be
that movie to see because the shots are
just gonna be insane from what I've seen
in the trailer the shots are absolutely
insane and so were the ones in the
original movie I mean people use those
plane you know those those aerial battle
shots those dogfight shots and literally
like every major movie after that and
television show that had a dogfight in
it for like the next they still do they
still use those shots from the original
movie so I'm sure they're going over the
top of this Tom Cruise is a producer so
they let
do whatever he wanted I don't know if he
can fly the plane or if they just set up
a camera in the plane and look like
somebody is flying them or something
yeah or in front of them because those
f-18s do have dual cut and it'd be very
easy to do that but he would still need
to be in it holding on to the g-force of
that which is that that's a whole thing
you know
so did you not out in the original Top
Gun what he asked for
like as part of his I know what you'd
call it like his like contract or
whatever with the original Top Gun uh
Tom Cruise yeah do you know what he
asked for what he asked for it he got to
have a flight with the Blue Angels oh
yeah so it was one of his things is like
he wanted to do that like go on the foot
go on the right along and stuff like
that with him he's like hey I gotta do
this got to kind of feel it for real so
I was getting with those things he got
to fly along with him and it's like oh
yeah he's gonna be so many cool things
yeah he's off the off the chain on stuff
now but it's like he's he's he's also
like I mean if I'm being perfectly
honest and I don't want to be dark about
it but Layton I when I heard they were
doing a Top Gun again oh my god I think
this is the movie that Tom Cruise is
gonna die doing I mean like like just go
Chris yeah like jets like you don't come
back from jets if you have an accident
and I've seen like the last couple of
Mission Impossible movies one thing when
he's the producer any they can't stop
him found him thing going to thing does
such crazy stuff and like lying I'm like
they're doing Top Gun I'm like okay it's
like seminal movie of his career mm-hmm
bringing it back the character one of
his most beloved characters on a
character yeah almost like kind of
characters I'm like he is gonna do so
many crazy things mm-hmm he's gonna die
[Music]
but he made it through so great maybe
we'll get another Top Gun but yeah I'm I
was more excited for that than probably
anything else no this is for the
cinematic you know like I mean it could
be a horrible storyline but the shots
stunts and everything last night what he
goes over that was nuts
oh yeah that's the shot right before
that with the fourth line up the fairly
low fairly low along the route water and
then they tore something it's got like
but it's like they turn over the water
and it's got like the Fritzl whatever
i'm sure there's a name for the effect
but it's like the fog that goes over the
plane like kind of the back wings as
they hit a hard turn and the four of
them hit it together yeah
it looks so cool so right yeah and when
they that dip over the well just up I
have a nostalgia like yeah claim I do of
all the glass a bunch of town doesn't
mean it's good it could be you looking
through rose-colored glasses like I look
to evoke the glass like you say I'm
aware and I get the poker I love this
could be the worst movie ever I'll see
it three times just exactly now you know
how I feel about the glassy if I can
roll my eyes hard enough it does a great
he'll roll those great disgust did she
display it I love it it's awesome
all right so that dropped the only other
major trailer I saw was well apparently
a trailer for a cats movie dropped in
people are not thrilled but haven't
checked too much of that I don't know
so and then I did see the trailer for it
too no I don't know if you guys are
horror movie people at all no maybe yes
yeah I watch it also you know you do so
and that was the thing for me sorry this
is not movie podcast for like five
minutes the last word and the movies
this is the aside project I'm here too
but honestly when it comes to like
horror movies I've seen a fair share of
scene the slashers I've seen the Gloria
ones I've seen a decent amount over time
but like the recent yet when I actually
saw it in theaters was a pleasant
surprise because it had multiple levels
to like the
like villains their fight it's not just
the clown like its king so it's always
gonna be a little darker but and that's
why I was like okay and then obviously
they set it up for a second one and
that's where it actually got really cool
for me is that like the cast is awesome
and if they do the second one as well
with like the plot twists and the depth
of the characters and things like that
that's what I can't wait for so kind of
looking forward to it too as well that's
actually not that far away either so
it's the fall yeah I'm assuming around
Christmas like October so I think it's
like September yeah that looks good too
I do like horror films I mean I loved
the original like television version of
it if you ever saw that that was nice so
freaky when I was a kid that was one of
those maybe there was the remake I
thought was pretty good too and yeah the
trailer was freaky of course a game I'll
give you with the thing stranger things
a little game yeah and then this is just
a little personal note if any of you
guys are car people out there I tweeted
it out as well but that's why I'm
wearing the shirt in honor because this
is the stingray shirt I got it at the
Corvette Museum so the brand new 2020
Corvette is is actually out there in the
wild the pictures are real so they were
revealed last night they did a whole
presentation kinda tied it in with the
moon landing and the astronauts and
stuff so they were talking about the
anniversary of that and actually like
for history if you guys don't know most
astronauts owned Corvettes like that was
a period and most astronauts educate me
sir it was basically just the fact that
like they wanted a lake I mean they're
driving spaceships they're going fast
like big and their pilots anyway so they
want like a speed and it was like the
American sports car so like June here
with NASA and it's like most of them had
like special versions or customized
there was one trio of astronauts they
each had like red white and blue and
then the pinstripes would be of the
other two cars so each one had all three
red white and blue colors on the car in
some way or another so they had kind of
a cool home etre back to that and just
kind of talking about the engineering in
the process and everything
I mean it's the first time Corvettes
ever been mid-engine in I mean it's been
made since 1953 so I mean it's been in a
very very very long time
mmm and yeah it's the first time for
mid-engine ever so it's a huge huge deal
so they took the front engine like
pushrod v8 about as far as they could go
so very curious what's what they see
next day one purchaser but get a very
it's like if I get a very different job
than we'll talk not quite that YouTube
windfall before that happens there you
go anyway all the personal stuff out of
the way but yeah the world is uh having
some fun stuff going on it is destiny
time so if you guys are like what are
they talking about this morning not
normal but between comic-con I couldn't
not mention Top Gun and for me I
couldn't know Mitch of the Corvette
itself
I said we got screaming with Phil guys
perfect we go off on the yeah scream and
I are over here cutting yours just this
is the last film with screaming that
Alba let you rock cuz I'll be missing
it's a big deal these are huge nostalgic
pieces you know I'm saying and bringing
them back and comic-con is always
exciting regardless of what like there's
always cool announcements at Comic Con
so
I got a respect your guys love and see
the Corvette love I do a shot King he's
big car that thing so I know he I put
them onto that what you get tweet that
you put out
I saw him tag it this morning when I
finally got out so well what has been
going on in the world of dusty how much
have you guys some playing what do you
guys been feeling about it right now I
know scream you've been getting your you
know for hours or so and every Tuesday
Cognito you've actually been hitting it
a little harder what do you guys feel
like about it right now just even the
current stuff like feeling it's good
feeling it's bad missing anything what
do you guys or the current feels I jump
off um I mean I'm loving it man it's
just like I said not I've been like
almost full-time again it's just some
really really enjoying him as so much to
do I think screen I mentioned
you know he was talking it's just like
there's so many things you can do you
know as far as light and activities just
locking out a whole bunch of quests I
noticed what I'm finding I'm finding
myself doing is multitasking bounties
and quests so that I'm maximizing the
most I can do at one time and um I know
scream we gonna get into it a little bit
about you know besides maximizing the
most you can do you maximizing efficient
strategies true or glitches that can
help you're probably working hard you
know you know I got scream on you know
he's got some cool strategies oh you
know I've been paying attention you know
same stuff as far as I know we gonna get
into that but um it's just it's been an
interesting time with the tribute hall
and menagerie and you know and obviously
we're getting the shadow key but I've
been it's been full time for me playing
a little bit of everything actually for
the first time really planning
everything and a shout out to Yui we got
a bender shout out to you two we got got
my shattered throne done old PC oh that
was so much fun and just it's funny
because when you play with he bounces
during his solo stuff he's still in his
solo mo so it's funny you have to like
put yourself in there like he's still
playing by itself so he's not he's so
used to handling everything by it so
then he's like oh yeah I got a little
help here he's not used to it it's funny
like sound like I this is cool
but literally the man put me in his
backpack and just you know I was just
showing me the way so shattered throne
was done I got one of my rare bounties
which I really wanted which was um a
black Armory bounty which required it
have a full without a folder for pieces
we found out right there four pieces of
black onyx again it could be a
combination of weapons or armor and then
um you know doing that and beat
shattered Thrones I knew I saw shattered
throne cause like there's no way I'm
doing scourge the press right
no way I'm doing last wizardry right now
it's gotta be shadow throne got a call
on the nightfall and shad his throne
soloist and get that done a shot at the
bender for coming and doing cool yoga
poses and making me laughter and it's
right
yeah we're in the end looking at Dylan
Carter I'm explaining the fight and then
they just bust out laughing I was like
guys okay it's like it's like you know
what it is scream like I get playing
with he does understand it's so natural
from he's like a professor he's like
he's teaching the course
right so you work in the back of the
class with your maid and your professors
talking but you're barely do a voice
he's doing emotes and I'm like yo
shout-out to y'all
shout out to eat for dealing with the
children in the back the class
messing up is perfect flawless runs
duct-tape myself to you and we're doing
any salute that was it for me was a bit
of what you scream what you scream what
you've been doing oh well yeah that's uh
you know always about working smart
[Laughter]
there's just so much to do as like a
solo guy you know that's outside the
realm of this stuff you have to you need
necessarily buddies to do everything
with although it's great to have a
friend like you bought us to Rome and I
saw that bounty I said I held on to that
bounty for like a week and a half I was
like there's a long window before you
get it done you're like artists bounty
I'm waiting
oh yeah continues but yeah I mean I love
the it's been I guess I mean I loved the
menagerie when that came out and
obviously that bag glitch that was in
the menagerie
oh the jest was a lot of fun mm-hmm are
you bad that some kind of gone now yeah
looking for another one I don't know if
it'll be found but yeah I loved I mean I
just loved all that I loved being able
to just kind of cue in and go it's sort
of like you know I I like the the forges
for that reason you
spike the footage I always thought the
for just felt sort of limited and I
wanted to always be able to do kind of a
a raid thing with six people randomly
and I thought that was like one of the
best things
yeah there's come in in mhm probably
forever as far as like the tribute hall
goes it's I like the challenge the thing
that I honestly like it can be it's a
frustrating thing in some ways like the
thing that I love about it is like I
don't mind going and just having to run
around like a little area and farm again
like d1 fields yes yeah some seriously
you know what was it in on the moon but
remember that material we used to farm
helium filling they're actually bringing
that section back to nice that's gonna
be something but yeah like I actually
like kind of doing that you know like it
wasn't it was just one of those things
that I'm sure a lot of people aren't as
entertained by as me but when you try to
when you think like efficient ways of
doing that
yes it feels very accomplished to be I
don't know why I want to jump in on that
too because literally what you're saying
is what I've been doing I've been it's
been it's like a playing like d1 style
where it's forcing me to engage in
different activities right for the
tribute yes Alexi for me I've been doing
for somebody wants me I love doing force
so I go there for word today you know
you do that or you play this morning not
get killed and play this and it just
makes you do different things and
different activities but in a cool way
and I don't feel it's like unfair I'm
gonna have you in there
super long you know I'm saying to the
the bounty percentages I don't know how
I feel about that but as far as the
activities yes and length I I'm which is
great I'm which other it's out yeah so
I've been you know I've been enjoying
that and I mean that's kind of really I
guess what I've been spending most of my
time doing is so it was I mean the first
couple of days
that tribute all came out I was just
farming as much as possible and trying
to you know see what the best way to
actually you know manipulate as much
currency as I could
to get what I needed hey how you been
getting that currency has that been more
of an active or passive method I I did I
did leave my computer on for like when
he came when he saw when I saw that I
was like oh my god I'm like I didn't I
don't know I realized it did it but I
didn't realize that you could just leave
it there like I never had left it there
for that long that was like the big
thing it is perfect it's so funny
because it's like you look at your
friends list now yeah main on discord
and you can see the populations and like
10% was for just like this week
everybody's like what other farming now
let me ask you a quick question in
reference who said forging noticing that
like at least at least on my end before
you could be passive right and do what
you got to do no the last I would say
maybe two or three days I've been
getting this you have to log back in a
little more frequently okay so I'm
thinking they may be trying to do
something passively
yeah that's like oh you're farming and
just like probably have some little BOTS
go around and be like what's the last
time they touch the mouse okay you're a
yep you're just like slowly walking
around checking on people yeah I thought
it was just me because I'm like the last
two days yeah I haven't gotten the full
effects of my passive hasn't woken up
with another thousand dust like shards
you know gotta get the full exactly
gotta get the full Turkey and the other
thing is your shout out to the spine I
think he's become one of the most fun
characters to now see it deftly with all
your you know newsroom role what's he
got baby
like he's like literally yeah oh for him
all I can picture is the Dave Chappelle
like little me more scratchy is you got
any more of that that's like you got any
more that Charlotte your bro whenever
you ready for these two materials right
here you let me know which you got for
these two right yeah I got a lot of
these specific two materials right here
so it's fun man shot the data lisen a
while despite as a hustler that's right
yeah that enhancement core is definitely
he'll say like oh one two three wait
what just happened the days where he's
selling whoa whoa femur for the
planetary material Oh tangled sure
that's a good day that was a good day
that's a good day you can make a lot of
glimmer real fast
oh I hit the ATM hard you know how many
withdrawals oh I was bite of everything
I've mentioned that like one like that
bounty glitch they patched it now but
that was I mean it I made quite a bit
during that period that was a good farm
oh well you could just go in and like
blast out the the boss before he entered
the final zone so it would mean you just
dumped the guest and leaders oh my god
you hit the chest on their way out it
was like you'd have like just this mind
of like every time he was dropping like
two legendary engrams and you're like oh
that was insane
I got no Sonic I'm the first one oh it's
amazing
yeah I gotta ask you a question you know
we're talking you know taking advantage
things
Oh
would you say if you had to write let's
do a little rent game would you say that
what is currently happening with forges
where would you rank that as far as
all-time destiny
exploits great victory well it is it's
so either difficulty quite high because
it's not that what to do set it up but
honestly game-breaking level not so bad
mmm
you're not getting a level gear you're
not throwing a plug on crota and getting
raid weapons not farming light engrams
of the loot cave each row shot the
profile it's like a there's yeah you can
go you can take all your materials you
can go to the planet you can get like
packages and you can get shards and
stuff that way but over the remaining
like by the way shout out to you to
reminded me to actually go cash in or
some of them vendors I was getting do
that could you yeah I was like I
wouldn't say that yeah doesn't compare
to the loot cave doesn't came to the
kurodo pole with the kneel all the glass
push off I mean you got all the glass
that was like yeah in the word yeah it's
actually really I mean as Dennis Dano
said it's like it's pretty harmless in
the grand scheme you're getting
materials you're easing up like to let
like there's two you didn't get you know
only get two you can't get them all so
like you still got to get shards you
still gotta get bright dust you still
you have to get the other two plane in
turn material so I mean if you still
want all the tributes legit it's still
gonna take some work but it is making
things easier probably gonna set you up
with more shards when it comes to like
the fall which is a big one so it has
benefits but it's not nearly as bad so
scream where do you you are the master
said exploits yeah it's because if you
really break it down it's really just
sort of one exploit for a specific
activity you know like it's you know
you're gonna get materials but you're
only gonna need that many materials
really for like the tribute hall at this
moment you know right right and then you
know if you want to catch up on some
later so you're not completely broke
when the next expansion comes out right
yeah
to your point before I think they are
now like checking it if you don't move
within every like I think five or so
resets they'll bill drop yeah I think
definitely think there's been a passive
fix that's right right on idle activity
right so you have to at least keep an
eye on it this is watch a movie and just
hit the inventory button every soft okay
get my full eight hours man oh you gotta
get that hey you're on PC now they make
BOTS for that that is investigate but uh
it's so bad when you want to PC it's
like what's everybody's but it's like
move to left move to the right turn fire
once turn left
yeah I was like all of you on console
have no idea like what it's like playing
with people in BOTS when they're on your
team oh man the frustration but yeah I
just brought it up because I just like
for me I haven't had a good one guy
turning left turning right and then
shooting at the ground once yes yep I've
had a good one in a while you know this
one the timing of it was great you know
shredding the damn tribute hall and it's
just been great as a person like as
Eno's I use materials are used cause I
use matera I am that guy I am trying to
maximize loadouts
I'm trying to have every subclass an
optimal you know I'm saying levels for
every situation that's that's me that's
just how I operate
though stuff something like this is
ranking very high for me because and
just the ease of use it's like literally
do nothing and walk away like that you
can't beat that on certain luck but I do
it he in a sense that yes the reward is
not you don't loot cave one level it's
not eighty on level type rewards and
stuff like that so you know it's it's
interesting in the grand pantheon of
destiny destiny has been broken and it's
in its own ways many times this will
definitely go down as one of them so
house
[Music]
yeah
so I know we've all been literally
sleeping on the job over here a little
bit definitely earn in some materials
trying to think what else we've got
so tribute hall do you guys have your
bad juju yet you guys have a catalyst
you have you guys she's dead did you get
to do the cheese missed out on the
cheese what about you scream um I
well the banner yeah the full catalyst
cheese I missed out I did a video on it
because I was like oh man it's like the
day after I started doing it and that
news came out so I was like ah come on
but I had to I had at least let
everybody else who hadn't started it no
but yeah I missed out on the fee being
able to just sort of plant the flag
thing I have I'm on the last step of the
bad juju but I know I'm on the mission I
have been waiting to do it because of
trying to again I'm gonna do it I'd
rather not do it straight forward so I'm
out the way you know wait to that moment
where I do it and I could just get cover
the most amount of cheese as possible
there's a few but I mean it's all the
whole mission I love the exotic quest
the exotic quest are probably one of my
favorite things to do honestly in the
game oh nice
I don't know if I ever always realized
that but like even looking back like
just doing the Thorin quest and d1 was
my favorite thing it was definitely my
favorite quest not just cuz I got the
thorn but I really like doing a luminous
quest so yeah I mean I've been enjoying
the time I do get to play is I mean and
then like you said there is just so much
to do
like I try to kind of plan out exactly
what I want to do before I even get into
the game because if I get into the game
without that I'm just gonna like walk
around the tower and pick up bounties
and let go I all right now I just got a
look at them in my giant proceed by
mosaic of my pursuit step don't get me
started on them
how about that pursued stab I'll burn it
to the ground I could do without it the
worst it is the that double press it's
the double press I figured it out
I hate that I have to go - clicks - this
stupid menu and then it's just it's just
an organ oh I hate it I hate it man
it's so confusing sometimes when I
wanted to focus there and then the fact
that I can't completely eliminate it
because I was like okay well maybe if
you just track what you want to do but
you only like limited to like three and
a few you know triumphs you get like
three and you can track one triumph one
triumph and it's just like as a person
and I got a shout out my boy carbide too
because I used to give him crap for
stuff like this we need to talk about
like destinies like you I didn't stuff
like that means work this is the first
time normally like I'm a very easygoing
guy right cuz generally I haven't had
that many issues but with the fact
there's so many pursuits there's so many
exotic questions so many steps then
these steps that when you complete it
even if you attract it the tracking gets
removed and then it goes to another step
so you like ah what am i doing next so
it comes down to me where it's like
efficient farming efficient playing
sessions right and the worst thing is I
have to startup destiny and literally
remind myself every hour - okay what am
I supposed to be doing next you know
it's just it's just like I said you just
want to be efficient and I'm hoping with
shadow key that gets fixed there I
cannot stand the pursue stamp right now
it is probably the worst it's ever been
for me yeah that one's weird because
I've seen people it was like you knew it
was bad when people in probably less
than 24 hours I think I saw like draft
someone Twitter and reddit and things
like that for like I mean UI graphics
people and stuff like that putting stuff
up and I don't and this is where it
comes to again the system's the game is
built on right right when it comes to
talking to you know yeah I got a chance
at Guardian con asking people about like
vault space and stuff like that and it's
like holds like one of the reasons they
can't really say but it's like there's
certain things well it's like so I went
and I had my brother and he and I looked
at him and it's like they load all five
pieces of that vault every time you open
here so it's like there's a rehabs like
the end you think about consoles what
they can do like what file size that is
and stuff like that and there is have to
develop for the lowest common
denominator so yeah I mean on PC it's
like yeah we may only have 500 we can
probably have a 5,000 who knows but that
would absolutely just like brick a
console so I mean there's a point to
where like there are certain things and
this has got to be something similar
when you look at the pursuit step they
wanted to add more so I don't know if
like then moving it to a separate space
on the director or on your social tabs
like gives them an option to have more
memory space because you don't load the
entire inventory when you put it in
there but now like the the spatial setup
of it is just weird like and but it was
the fact that people fix it like 24
hours I was like that looks good that
looks good that looks any of those look
good
like compared to what we got so I don't
know like I I do think it means reviewed
when those well gets a couple other
things I don't see it in the fall
unfortunately because they just got all
please please please
I mean I guess if I gotta sacrifice
something for cross save and a good play
even great campaigns and some strikes in
some you know I guess I could wait
another expansion for this damn annoying
pursuit that would you think there what
do you think scream yeah I mean it's
just it's it's very counterintuitive to
why I want my pursuit stab as far as the
way it is now but again it's like I can
understand if we need to do something to
sort of in I mean let it seem like it
was there to kind of level the playing
field a little bit between people who
had PC and consoles as far as like how
like the load time of that you know like
III was that exactly did they give that
as a reason why they instituted
obviously no chance to dive deep with
them at Guardian cause like it's all
speculation they're not gonna give away
true yeah that might be speculation but
it seems like that was what it was for
and I can understand that because
there's a significant amount of people
who are playing on console
it's the beach right and and also like
if you're going for like a world's first
you know like I mean it's people on PC
will always have an advantage because
they they just have like such a shorter
load time when it comes to like anything
so I don't know if that all if that
helped a little bit in that I mean that
did come out right before the last I'm
trying to remember exactly when the
pursuits that was instituted that way
was it right before the last raid was
released it was before a raid release so
you know I I I can deal with it because
we did get so much good stuff but I wish
there was kind of a way like I kind of
wish they just organized it a little bit
better like automatic you know like like
your new things come in like left to
right like you're reading a book you
know like even that would make it so
much easier pregel for each brother for
each so even if they just did like a
little change like that in the interim
you know I might even just be fine with
that period I don't know what they're
gonna do but mmm which is great it'd be
nice to like I've seen some where they
have like all the bounties in a corner
they have like one strip for specific
stuff and then on the right they have
bigger icons and maybe you could even
pick like you know drag one over there
and be like I'm working on the lumina
quest it always lives in this big giant
icon so I know where to go for it don't
have to like some customization - it
would be nice for our end because yeah
you can sort but it feels like if I saw
it I just break it more sometimes like
new as oh yeah most like rarity and I'm
like what hold on what did I just do it
like every time they had a button I feel
like it's just worst and for the love of
God can we please put the pinnacle
weapon steps out of the triumphs and
into the bounty so I can see the
progress and that that's the search for
the specific quotation name of what the
step I'm doing like yeah like I find out
the body be like finish the pursuit of
Honor quest you like well what is that
like what did you fumbling do the trying
like where is and you can't you can only
highlight one of those and it's just
like that remember when me
clean e and you all would do a shot at
throne what kind of sad that sounds
crazy and you're like yo that's
twenty-one delirium right and I'm like
oh that's crazy because I play a lot of
gambit but because I can't efficiently
track all my steps my acquisition of
delirium is suffering because I'm not
paying attention not being able to pay
attention to where I am with the invoice
and infamy reset and I literally had to
just start doing that now cuz you
reminded me because you had delirium
when we were playing together sorry I
was reading chat and say that again no
it's okay last part not the whole thing
the last part about Bill you're not just
delirium just how we were playing
together and how you know the whole fact
of the matter is that I was like you
know so cool and then you're like yeah
you play a lot of cam but I'm like yeah
but I don't know what the quest name is
and where I am with the steps you know
after we play shadow throwing I looked
and I finally got a chance to see where
I'm at with it but because it was
through so many sub men using deep
diving and uh yeah they need to way need
to find a way and I think most of that
and then par five I'll get to your
question in a second yeah par fives
getting a question I see late motion
what they've got what they're trying to
do there is they're trying to take them
away from character specific like they
had with Lunas Hal and take them to
account specific with triumphs because
there's those are tracked account-wide
so you can have a boundary but Transtech
to account wide the annoying thing about
that is somehow they figured out that
out with the new bounties for like sabre
poker and hush if you pick up a bounty
it tracks across so those are there but
yeah the old ones are still annoying so
like that's like a learning process that
they went through hey let's have a
bounty okay there should be a count
later okay let's do this account-wide
let the triumphs that we know those work
you can't wait okay okay now we got the
bounties but you have to pick them up on
every character it's like have a way
when you when I log in on my account
somewhere and be like account why bounty
Lake something should just be like
permanently stuck somewhere and again I
don't know how their systems are built
so that's like that's it no but that's
that's definitely an ask to be like if
there's an account light bounty that
gets its own home like certain things
like
those the triumphs related ones don't
have it that like and again as also
Danno said give me numbers I don't care
if you want me to get 15,000 points be
like hey every kills five winning a
match is 100 like if you gotta get
15,000 at least you can do the math or
is like get a hundred percent on this
bounty I'm like what does that mean
now you can actually go today like what
to help now you can go to things like
destiny item manager go to progress and
then you can look and hardcore players
know about damn and honestly if you sit
on a computer you're better be using dim
or you're playing the game wrong but
it's still like why do I have to click
on that I shouldn't have to that should
not be that the numbers in the game and
I'm hoping maybe from the little Armour
2.0 discussion we get into look like
they might be more in the game in the
fall but again they said they destiny
still has been like more they've always
said they wanted everything to feel good
but they don't want you to get you know
too deep in the numbers well I'm hoping
the word on MMORPG and all that stuff
starts changing those things so yes sir
yes I hope we get into par 5 yep so
question thank you par 5 for jumping in
as well he said I have a friend I play
with on ps4 every weekend you and a lot
of people I'm sure a lot of people
aren't ps4 a lot of people roll on Xbox
they're on both but they're on console
really thinking about evening shadow
keep on B keep PC because the better
performance and graphics should I buy a
copy for both PC and ps4 so that I can
keep playing with my friend but enjoy
this a little bit if it's a PC now my
answer is if you have the money yeah yes
yes if you can play on PC you have a rig
that runs it yes absolutely main reason
you for one controller is easy to use so
you can just literally plug it in and
you're good to go
Cognito showing off his Xbox elite so
humblebrag there Thank You vana I
appreciate it
the other piece is mostly like your
have a steam friends list which is gonna
be huge you've got actually that whole
world that they're dealing with new
light players are gonna be coming
probably quickest from Steam so you're
gonna have a bigger population to play
with as well if you're doing as again if
you're playing Celebi like I need to go
run strike so you need to go run PvP
you're gonna go play PvP again it's like
10 million blueberries welcome it's
gonna be a lot of them so I would if you
have if you have the funds yes if you
are limited on your funds and all your
friends are on one place like ps4 start
there but if you have the funds and you
have the computer do it 100% absolutely
scream do you compare yeah yeah yeah I
think it's just the game is much more
enjoyable you can actually you know I
always found having been an xbox one
player before I went to PC that true and
playing I mean playing all of d1 on on
xbox obviously because it wasn't amazing
but then switching over indie to like I
played the first three months I think of
d2 on
and even then the load times on Xbox oh
it's so much longer that you would get
really kind of like mmm like it'd be one
of those things where it's like okay I'm
loading into a place alright this is
gonna take like three or four minutes so
I'll put my controller down and I'm
gonna go yes go do some go yeah but then
I but the thing is like I come and do so
go do something and then I get
distracted a night you know all right
I'm gonna put the game away and I
wouldn't like really get engrossed like
I do you know so that alone not to
mention the fact that because yeah
you're gonna get all those people coming
in from Steam mmm yeah I think I
honestly think that the player base is
gonna completely Oh Schatzi
big-time and uh you know you'll just be
getting games that much faster with that
many more people it's only going to
increase the experience even more so yes
yes but I understand want him to play
with friends
yeah absolutely you know like I can
understand that is that's a good reason
enough to stay for something I think to
an extent but yeah but if you got the
option baby go bad the option yes that's
that's why I mean that's why I think and
that's a lot of people who've been
playing I mean you've got like creators
like you know some of the live you got
you know cool guy was on he's an Xbox
guy all that we knows on ps4 it's like
there's a lot of good on consoles
because like win the time to switch over
to PC didn't happen and then they're two
years into the destiny to character and
you're like there's no way in hell are
you doing this grind you you made the
switch later and it's still been you
know struggle on some things it's like
people go to it yeah good to you so I
was just gonna say seeping just
literally click a button your save is
everywhere and you're like yeah now it's
time don't get no better than that
so criminally underrated how that
feature is going to bring the
communities the player bases altogether
I think destiny is going to be I think
that single feature alone is huge in
September and honestly or I think I said
this TV I know we had the whole new
Borderlands discussion thing I think
that feature Leno is enough to hold off
without even more limbs as it or Ellen
says cross played doesn't is the first
big one to really have this cross
they've been going on and I mean cuz
there's other games I've had you know
cross sale besides you know fortnight
and stuff like that which is which is
paid but in terms of like the you know
Mura shooter space desk these first man
and this is man this is huge
well quick pull up just cuz I had to
google it first shout-out to gaming
industry dot biz just cuz it's near the
collect on your BOTS gearbox commits to
cross play for Borderlands 3 this
feature will not be available
immediately but same thing division said
you know we want to do it we want to do
it early because I was like I thought
I'd heard talk about it and I just
honestly wasn't sure so
the only one that surprised me out the
box doc that was call of duty call duty
said they were doing missions that's the
one okay that's big for call to do know
that's big yeah yeah I think call duty
need something big yeah being the series
been on the decline slightly and you
know I get it I mean that's a huge
community as well so that's a game
that's gonna benefit but destiny there's
no doubt there's so many people even
mine you know my podcast makes all the
other lords they like you PC like
they're like they're not giving up their
character and their grind to start fresh
they refused how could I argue with them
right you've all done whisper and
escalation protocols and raid on prison
who wants to you know like cuz of my
love for II I gave it all up I gave it
up you had the opportunity for the PC
and it was free so timing I left my
friends
I broke the friendship comb and I did
all for he last word [ __ ] is like I'm
all things you did it for at least you
do you're playing with the guy you do a
podcast with the game for so that is
true that is true and I get some free
raids and shouted throws out of this so
that's that's good there's some backpack
space occasionally if you can exact out
a cache hit those chips though to
guilt-trip one get some free stuff out
of me you now Willie K but it was that
that deal they basically did the free to
play on PC first with me in a sense
without on there so it was a no-brainer
it was just the beginning is rough
though we have enough that all made like
a kindergarten out there with the blue
who's it was not good yeah it was
actually good for you to can have
perspective when it comes to materials
and the grind and stuff like that
because you were a little fresh into
starting over here like hey what's your
currency situation like some saving
better than others but unlike say even
for me though I wouldn't be in the same
place I am with like my materials if I
was starting when you did so like people
who come in fresh are gonna have a
completely different thing like an feel
for what
the enhancement core economy like what
are my plans certain materials why do I
have to go grind these what are these
planetary bounties like what is
happening so there's different things
you've got to picture because like we're
all hardcore if you're probably listen
to this if the three of us are on here
most our guests were hardcore Disney
players we have a lot of everything done
multiple times over we're not like oh
I'll pick it up for a couple hours in
the weekend maybe do a strike maybe you
know try and matchmaking here don't try
any of the big stuff much less like oh
wait they're bounties that the gunsmith
like if you're not like watching you
know watching the viaduct so if you're
not catching the bungie.net like blog
articles you may not have a clue half
the stuff that's in here so but cliff
lacks I was like for the first time
average feel just like get on booted up
oh yeah other strikes over here some
crucible or gambits here cool like oh
this is a new thing for me too new
campaign thing for me to work on with
the forges but yeah there's a lot so
cross-play heels friendships oh my god
play would you get to play with me again
but of course I got to be arrogant
screen when I when I come down to Xbox I
got a black hold on it is Lord Cognito
that has ascended down from the master
race to deal with my loyal subjects here
the lowly console back to your 85% view
ratio yes I'll help you
what is the screen shake I feel oh man
what else we got what's going on with
these five it's going all those destiny
streets main so obviously we've been
playing having some fun we are close to
shadow keep and we've actually got a few
articles thanks to polygons a couple
interviews with the gentlemen they kind
of are breaking the interview segments
up and dropping some knowledge from
those two the big ones we've got so far
one of them something we're all looking
forward to Mortal Kombat style
we got finishing moves oh so I'm gonna
give you as a brief rundown then I want
to get you guys thoughts about how they
actually kind of work basically for
finishing move
basically they say it's gonna be a mod
for your for an armor slide and they're
gonna think of it as combat emotes so I
don't know if you'll get you'll probably
get one a functional one to start off
with and then they're almost gonna be
something to where you can get probably
potentially more from ever verse so it's
gonna throw a little flash and flair I'm
sure they will give you one for the
function of like you know doing what
needs to actually happen but the other
cool thing about finishing moves which
we didn't know until this article
actually came out was kind of the
benefits to them so the benefits of a
finishing move it's kind of a
risk/reward situation so say I equip one
that's going to turn the enemy into a
loot pit or not a loot but say an ammo
pinata when I finish them so drop a
bunch em on the ground but it's the risk
of getting up there and actually getting
in close range and there's gonna be
different finishing moves that actually
are gonna be able to do different things
for you so they're gonna work kind of
cosmetically some may be coming from
ever verse like they're actually gonna
be rare some may be purchasable things
like that but I'm sure the function
hopefully will be in-game but just the
fact that they do have function maybe
ammo pinata or who else maybe it's like
nail it everybody gets like an over
shield on your team or maybe a damage
buff or something like how do you guys
think that's gonna go any like once for
abilities or anything like that
scream what do you what do you think I
hope that's a dragon tail kick that's
the best one already
I want a dragon tail to a fan kick and
all aw pose I don't think anybody and I
yeah I mean I I I think that the system
that they're doing is I think it's the
best way to do it I'm sure there's gonna
be some interesting exploits that are
gonna come in early on there's always
like alright so the finishing what you
can do is you can punch the boss into
wall he gets stuck their name right you
just to--for an hour and he won't do
damage to you and if you drop a red
banner at this moment you got infinite
ammo and supers if you hit the super
glitch ammo bubble bug like oh my god
so yeah I think it's gonna be a lot of
I when I when I first saw it I was like
what is this like it is just like an E
is this just like you like like you know
dropping some Flair on him after you
kill them you know like like like salt
okay I don't think it's quite like
Mortal Kombat we're sitting there and
kind of that drunken stupid new shoe and
it's gonna be like and then you go up
and actually uppercut him right no I
would love to do that to kurta that
would I was wondering if it was like you
have to beat a boss to a point in them
like at some point somebody has the
option to go up and do that or if it was
actually like a risk versus reward kind
of situation that has like a bonus so
I'm glad it is because it obviously
makes room for a lot more a little bit
more manipulation of it but so yeah I
mean it's it clarified like it's a very
cool but they did say like when enemies
go below a certain health threshold
they're gonna have an indicator that
means they can be finished he's ready
you're gonna be able to know right so
yeah I think it's gonna be I think it's
an interesting thing it wasn't like a it
wasn't ever something I thought would
like finishing moves I was alright you
know like I see you bungee I see but uh
yes so one of their more creative forays
and I don't know where I think Edie
Boone made a studio visit was like hey
how's bungee going could you finishing
moves in there it worked for us you
should do it too and then yeah it's like
what it's gonna take to actually use the
finishing move is super energy even
though they say how much is still in
flux so cognate kognito what about you
what are you thinking about them it's
just I you know Bungie I mean it's like
you say like thanks for stuff like that
like that's the last thing I would think
would come to destiny but I could
already visualize the implementation if
like um
shout the Lord at it cuz like he's that
guy right he's the guy that when you're
fighting the boss he wants to get the
last hit and he's like yeah like you
know who's my Titan was the reason like
so him to have this ability for an
indicator to put this fist not a
question
is gonna be for me is it limited to read
in yellow bars you know I'm saying
orange bars right autumn yellow boredom
boss bosses are we gonna be able to hit
up Calais like I don't know about that
right you know it's so I I guess I'm
curious as to who the enemies that
applies to but even if it's just
everyone - you know those mega mega
bosses still a cool feature you know
it's gonna add a lot of visual flair to
it
you know you know bungees gonna get and
again they've already mentioned ever
[ __ ] and one thing I don't mind and I
think II have had this discussion with
you is when it comes to fix your face
boy when I was like you tell me I'm like
this is good oh is that is that when I
had discussion with you in there's two
implementations of ever verse like
people don't realize that's the type of
game II will spend that money for cool
emotes we will spend that money without
question I have a Michael Jackson one
that just literally like mom I literally
think I could like literally just buy
the same you were to say it's have a
time and it's just like now think about
all the fun karate movies pop culture
you're gonna have like like scream said
if people gonna be doing dragon kicks
and you know say like they could really
take this somewhere right like I'm
laughing at bender doing yo could you
imagine Bruce Lee one-inch punch in a
boss and my god fool did the boss flies
like better be there it's gonna be so
late actually I want this finishing move
one of your excruciatingly difficult
shouty he's got a great video hour
please yeah and watch this video the
stages of a solo player grief yeah oh
great hilarious like bad you go to all
and you
get it done and that that indicator pops
up on that boss after all those
unsuccessful runs and he gets to do what
he wants to do to that what the boss
that was tormented him oh I already know
is gonna be legendary
it's a great feature I'd be a nice way
to finish like a video and be like I was
like whatever boss you're working on get
them loan just run up and be like just
like right through and just send them
off that'd be amazing that would be
really cool it that'd be like some good
highlight I see some highlight reel type
YouTube clips or a montage of finishing
moves or something like that definitely
happening so hopefully we're allowed to
have some fun with those this could be a
little cash cash card on the revenue
stream I'm telling y'all Ben this is
gonna be another one this is ingenious
what they're doing in so far solo
bungees minnows on fire right now with
these door processes though we shall see
yeah I mean we've got ornaments coming
out of every verse you've got these
types of things positional it was like
yeah it's like y'all spend money on that
a little bit here and there but it's
like we all know what's going to Bungie
like it's 100% there's now like that's a
little better
facts man I know like they're gonna be a
lot of fun I'm looking forward to I
don't know you guys said some awesome
ones already the snap would be cool but
it's not gonna it's but the one-inch
punch that's really cool a dragon tail
whip if it could be an awesome car tail
you can swing it that way but yeah I'm
just a big uppercut just seems like cuz
you have the uppercut he had like a big
I know the cross I think was Dave
Samuels in the video he's talking about
me like he winds up looks at us fist and
then punches again what oh the hunter
does like the kind of horizontal spin
for like a double knife knife attack so
there's some pretty cool ones that I
remember and that's just the ones
they're starting with so they can keep
adding those yeah but yeah I'm with you
guys I never expected to see it no so in
the viaduct I was like finishing moves
it's that thing you didn't know you
needed funny if they had a snap one
where as soon as you do it like if
you're in a party like - you're funny
you're like you're in the rain you're
like
and they like to fade away until they
walk again in the pop-culture references
if they want to take it there and
legally you know they're gonna probably
ask on the snap that's a little yeah
that's very cuz I do remember things
coming out about like fortnight dances
and it was the mmm but those game
studios have one shout out to a whole
law I had them on our podcast I had this
exact topic and I was like hold man do
these content creators do the
originators of the you know these moves
do they have another thing is where you
may be right II is that dance moves for
my understanding is much harder to fight
yeah now these are like maybe I kind of
finishing moves and poses I don't know
you know I've resisted this will halt
glad to get them all I just question
ladies could go that's definitely
something they don't need to like piss
off somebody for a lawsuit so they'll
probably play it play easy unless they
can work it should talk to whoever does
the marketing for Tekken I love me some
Tekken screen especially because they
have all the finishing moves up like so
many classic like you know martial
artists I mean there's something from
everybody so I wonder what they do
seconds been getting away with it
forever like they've literally have
Bruce Lee and Jackie Chan in their game
so does week right so yeah that's a good
point a may be able to get away with
lock this stuff so finishing moves will
be awesome looking probably my biggest
thing and I still don't have that much
clarification on it is marmar 2.0 here
we go so you open this up to you guys
first I'm gonna give a little intro of
just kind of what we got from the
polygon article basically they did
confirm it's gonna have an energy system
so you power up the armor to increase
its capacity which lets you equip more
mods the stats we know are coming back
they said mobility or hold on no
intellect discipline strength those are
all returns and they also send mobility
resilience and recovery are going to
have a bigger they're gonna widen the
range of those three mm-hm
so the range of I guess the abilities so
hopefully it actually does
bit more but they don't know quite what
that means and they also said you're
gonna be able to do things like stack
and this is where I'll kind of let you
guys dive deep while I take a little
breather for a sec um so say your you
like hand cannon reloading well you can
put two hand cane and reload things on
there and actually double stack towards
that but say because when you looked at
the picture before cuz I broke down the
one frame in the damn viaduct you had
like recovery and it had like it was
worth five energy and then you look like
you had recovery and it was worth three
energy so I'm kind of wondering one so
these are the questions I want to ask
you guys or I guess here's three parts
one thoughts about this whole system
thoughts on it anymore the little
tidbits that we got to do you think
these like if you double stack is it
just gonna be the same as what we have
now like is the weight of the new stuff
gonna have are you gonna have to really
go specific for a build or do you think
aerosol are gonna be better than we are
now and then three how do you guys think
we're gonna get the mods especially
things like enhance sniper rifle
targeting that currently is only on like
dreaming city or raid armor where do you
think the enhanced ones may come from
stuff like that so scream Cognito
whoever wants to go first
okay wait babe what you got I'm
personally into this I mean this was one
of those things that I was always kind
of like a 13 tier kind of like questi
guy in g1 like that was similar one of
the things I spent a lot of time trying
to my character so I'm into any system
that promotes more of that yes I like
the breakdown of it and it was one of
those I mean honestly was something that
I thought didn't need to go when they
turned in when d2 came out and I've
missed it since then and now that seems
like they're even going I don't know if
it's necessarily gonna be I feel like
it's probably gonna be as involved as
the system as in d1 mm-hm
which I think it was almost by accident
but it became very you know like a good
way to spend your time once he hit that
like whatever the power cap was at any
given expansion and so I think the way
that they're sort of bringing in
more ability or it's like they're
bringing which ones are they bringing
back are they bringing back
they're bringing the Nationalists
they're bringing back discipline
discipline okay that was the right so
those three in electricity strength and
the arm remember the current ones are
still gonna exist so right resilience
recovery still there today adding right
so I think like the add of those three
is probably gonna call you know like
amount to how involved it was in d1
which is I don't know if it'll be more
than that hopefully it is I think you
are gonna be mainly like going for a
specific build I I mean I I don't know
if that'll necessarily be mm-hmm like
you know how sometimes it's like they
retract from what is there to allow you
to build more specifically in the talent
tree ID right right rather than just
building on top of oh you are currently
so like because I think if you were able
to specifically build specifically from
like where it is now is like a base you
might be like pretty godly if you really
went for it you know write a good say
they are worried they are still tuning
write the article as far as power levels
and stuff like that so I think they're
gonna have to sort of tune it down
slightly to account for that as far as
like where the mods will come from I
mean I hope they come from just like I
hope it's simple but I hope it's you
know like knife all bosses or or their
plea ssin of like not the highest level
activities but you know some sort of mid
level activity maybe something that
requires a group of three oh god you
know I'm trying to think maybe like you
know I mean even like the forges you
know maybe like well maybe not a forge
but like maybe an occasion drop from
like a forge boss you know something
like that I think would be good or maybe
if you have so many different of this
thing you can turn it in for one maybe
you have so many different mods you can
turn them in for one I don't know if
they really break it down where they
hope those come from but that would be
what I would give for personally yeah
what you man I mean this is good stuff
this is good stuff and shout-out to my
article that I
put out overlords gave me that net this
morning I actually was talking about
this specifically and um basically you
know to me when I hear this stuff I
think of them getting back to RPG
sensibilities right getting back to that
MMO path that we all want that's gonna
be and I think this is to start right we
begin trans mom beginning this other
stuff um that's a big one
that's a huge one huge one man so we
gotta give it up you know when possible
I know II will upset in the article that
they specifically mentioned and I touch
this up class he's gonna you're gonna
you're gonna bring that work in a minute
he's chomping that lips with the lip
this did exactly that that I already
know so so the thing is though like for
me armor is so near and dear to me like
again in my article I even said it which
is like it we always get weapon balances
problem yeah oh it Alma has been out
here suffering you know then so to have
this um these new features was really
refreshing to me shout out to the
chaplains he'll bear I gotta see if this
is being super mods are now going away
is this their way of controlling that
whole thing where people stack in the
five you know mods or whatever based on
you your gear set um the thing that
excites me is the growing with power
level on your gear so the thing where
they mention with like okay as you keep
playing and you're doing things you get
unlock an additional mode and he
mentioned you know having the the two
hand cleaning slots for reloading or
whatever whatever so there's gonna be a
lot of balance and involved things can't
get too crazy so I think they're gonna
nerve some abilities currently you know
some mods like I should say currently
but um I kind of like it I like the
configurability because at the end of
the day like this is where I currently
stand with destiny and armor and this is
why II he teases me right about why my
wasting material this is why like I am
that guy I'm like yo today I'm running
low I got four bounties and I need
linear fusion rifle kills guess what I'm
running I'm running my helmet I'm
running reserves my arms I'm running
selenium fusions Gavin I
literally have an armored piece set
aside for every single type of weapon
bill so I have maximum ammo maximum
reserves on pickups even with hand
cannons that I like you know I'm not
have looks the way it does bro it dis is
how I am I'm I'm the creature of that
minutia right so now you feel me speedy
right you know I'm telling that true we
gonna preaching the word right there use
it so it's like the thing with me is you
know now you're telling me okay I can
because another thing about this he
let's be real it's the fashion game
right we there's some shout out today to
the art team destiny is a beautifully
designed as far as armor is concerned in
aesthetics you can really mess with this
game in that so when you get a good
piece of alright and you like oh great
grenade launcher scavenger okay you're
right look like primary ammo reserve
boots boots and chests can all just go
out just there done like I don't know of
a boot or a chest that I actually care
about when it comes to flinch with
shotguns primary primary ammo finder
because I'm struggling to get my
primaries Oh
ever see you like traction and it's just
some things I look at it and I'm like
why is this even slot you know that
means I like you said chess especially
so now you're telling me you're giving
me the ability to customize the way that
the armor that I like the flag in and I
like into these specific ways you're
gonna have identity with that character
that's where the trans marks energy and
all this stuff is really gonna come
together so I am about all of this I'm
curious to see how deep it go um I'm
curious to see if it's gonna be a d1
thing screen where remember d1 where
like the more and you got an exotic and
d1 and you got all those bubbles
right how are they go ahead with this
mr. Nobles should cover them up by your
Britain know that that crime was hard
they'll remember you like him
I need 450 more spin metals I got the
next iron banner huh you like damn I'm
happy I got it but now the work begins
[Music]
daddy oh no I was like when you say that
about earning the bubbles back I know a
lot of people don't want that back and
I'm not trying not like goes for it but
no I'm I'm I've always wondered why
something about destiny too has felt
different than d1 and it has been that
like the connection you get like the
investment you put into it like this is
the good gun this is the one I want to
get into is it I've always wondered what
like what has felt different about d2
and I always kind of wondered if it's
that and I'm getting feedback a little
bit from one of you guys yeah I mean
it's it's it's dead uh I call it
emotional investment you know saying cuz
when you you put in that work you feel
attached I think the closest I feel with
that in d2 right now which I love a lot
its catalysts because you get that
catalyst right screen like yo you see
what the potential could be when it
someone so then you know okay what I got
to do you know I'm saying first what do
I have to do to try to get right what
activity I have to do and then it's like
okay when I do get it to drop okay what
do they want me to do to fill it out and
like one of them up the one that I
really want so bad as a badge of honor
because you know how much I love the
sleeper is the sleeper catalyst you know
and I'm still working on it I finally
got all my three EP weapons on thing I
still got to do the whisper stuff with
you and sinister and then I got to do
that damn raid spire you know I'm saying
to get it but it's it's like a badge of
honor of your commitment to that weapon
and I kind of like that and I think
that's the closest d2 has come to d1 in
that room that's it one catalyst I
wasn't no no sorry no no go ahead cows
like catalysts have have have been nice
since they came in but go ahead
I was a yeah like the the thing in d1
that probably the catalyst field is
similar as the most similar to and d1
was like the necrochasm boom like that's
kind of how like a cask to an extent
it's I mean and that's that was one type
of exotic quest in d1 yeah but it was
definitely an emotionally involved one I
was just grinding that one guy for hours
wait for the drop it I remember I
started that when they like had docked
the drop rate of it - and they didn't
tell anybody for a lay I was like you're
like dude I've been out here for hours
killing this guy well what happened
right yeah for real mm-hmm but for me
basically what I'd say is like Armour
2.0 I've got more questions than I've
got answers now so it just opens up more
doors the energy system for me is
interesting because my curiosity's say
you power up the armor to increase its
capacity which lets you equip more mods
okay it's like I know when you max it
out you'll be able to equip more fine
how do you power it up do you pay for an
enhancement course to pay for it
legendary shards do you pay different
I'm used in activities like how do you
get the energy on this thing I'd love to
know we don't know squat so that's like
more questions and I got answers but it
is an energy system they clarified that
when it comes to the stats now we have
six of them I'm wondering because right
now armor stats don't matter right
correct they don't like I literally went
to do my leg solo high-roller nightfall
build for this week and while I didn't
equip Menagerie armor cuz it really
didn't matter like go where Menagerie
armor but armor doesn't matter like I
went in there with just like all garbage
perks did not matter what I wore I was
just literally power 750 and that's the
only thing that matter and then my
weapons I was like okay I gotta be able
to handle the shield so those the
important part armor who gives a crap
like it that's kind of the point I'm at
with armor right now and have been for a
while because you loser like NAR my
vault is stupidly full because I have it
like reserve scavenger like if I get a
helm that has like what would it be like
machine gun Dexter
and machine-gun reserves and then I get
arms that have like machine guns
scavenger and miskeen machine gun reload
or I'm like dude I'm like set for
machine guns sweet I'm feeling awesome
about it yeah but that is the only thing
is it as related to my weapons let's
keep it a buck yah I'm a shot question
who really out here master working or am
i right no all right screen while you
master working or not master worked one
myself the only the only time I did at
one time was literally just to see how
many cores it would take so I could do
the math I thought it would cost that is
the only time I have ever mastered
armors to see how much one piece cost so
I would know the total picture of master
working an entire loadout yeah remember
you did the stat right 96 course
oh no that's never good no I was just I
didn't for what benefit right was like
oh you have 50 so it would be every
piece of armor would be a every core
base of every level is worth one percent
of damage reduction so say you like all
the pieces you wore were like arc
resistance and you had a full set that
you actually liked which is hard enough
if it was all arc resistance then you
would have like a 25% I think arc
resistance mmm and then I think you're
super would have some benefit to it too
but like it's pretty minor for the cost
that you get out of it in the situations
where you'll use it you have three
different types of damage coming at you
so honestly it's like you probably could
spread out a little bit and be better
off who's gonna spend all the damn cores
like why like that that was a completely
lost functionality even when they did
that was like I mean in the started due
to we didn't have like we had squat we
didn't have perks we're hit the starter
d2 so we got perks that was a step in
the right direction but like the old
master working tiny those wastes right
try again and they are trying again cuz
we've been talking about armor like
exotics and all those things now here's
the question I just literally popped in
my head because exotics now what if like
a new like all the our exotics you have
they don't have the new stats on them
right those like new stats new maybe mod
salon
are they gonna be specific mods that
they keep how are all these exotic
armors that we already have which some
are better than others but how are those
gonna drop indeed three deep shadow heap
scream I have an avid theory Oh scream
you go first I'll go they've got it
they've got to do the old-school thing
where it's like you get it again and
it's the 2.0 version you know that you
can't touch the existing ones those ones
I've already kind of baked in set in
stone I can't see them doing anything
with that so I think it's gonna be a
situation like Houser does now right
moszer comes around he's got the random
roll on said armor piece or said you
know whatever they're gonna have to
introduce that all I'm hoping is that
destiny is sitting on so many cool armor
sets that they bring these things
forward so that we can have more
diversity with the way we look that's my
main thing so we have the version with
the way we look weird all these feature
sets I'm cool with that but now if
you're telling me we're gonna do this
new thing kind of like weapons 2.0 right
you know but there's still a ton of
weapons that we still like yo fam when
is this gonna get you know looking at
you perfect paradox you know I'm like
I'm looking my perfect products like
damn I really want to you know do
something with this and it's just like
I'm not gonna spend all this you know
money you know as far as an investment
for you know that's why I got what about
you scream yeah I agree I you know it's
honestly kind of one of those things
where I when it comes to exotics I
always especially exotic armor I always
find there's one piece of exotic armor
that I always use you know like it's and
it just it's always kind of like why am
I gonna use like I mean there's things
with the just for an example like with
my warlock where I can get a I can get a
pretty good super rollin in my if I use
Nova bomb and I'm trying to rubber the
helmet but it gives you like instant you
know oh let's go let's go right but like
why am I gonna use that when my arm
Steen I think it's the Karen Steen
armlets yeah help back every single time
is Helen enemy you know it's like very
underrated exotic right right so I
almost never use anything but them as
far as like getting them back in a
different way I hope there's like a way
where if you if you have them you can
like if you have the old version you
trade in for the new version like on a
chance I you know like like maybe I
don't know if they've have they gone
into specifically any ideas that they
have for how you trade up or is this
complete it's complete speculation
complete speculation at this point
really yeah it really be tight look I
want to make sure I wasn't missing
something I would hope maybe like
there's a way like sazar you can trade
in your old ones like turn them in and
you get like a token that you can redeem
that gives you like a orangey roll on a
new piece of 2.0 you know that kinda now
everything I mean it's not specific or
maybe it's just a random roll for that
specific piece but you know beyond that
I'm not totally sure I'll I'll watch
with scream you cut out the a little
scream oh I'll say oh sorry I'll watch
with a waited breath know something like
that but you just cut off it was like
your watch with and we're like romantic
yeah my question honestly is mostly
gonna be about how the hell we get the
mod components like I've got you know a
reverie dawn helm that has enhanced
sniper rifle targeting in a you know
notorious chest that has enhanced sniper
rifle dexterity like am I gonna be able
to break those down and pull the mods
off of them is that old stuff is
literally like shadow keep gonna be a
line and it's just everything's new
going forward it's like those are some
of the questions cuz honestly crap I'll
go through and delete most of my unless
it's just like perfect stuff that might
kind of tide me over till I get some
good rolls like unless it's those like
I'll dump everything if I knew that but
I don't think it's happening I think
it's happening honestly okay with it
yeah I think
oh and I'll be okay with it too I'm
saying it like because I think didn't
they already kind of start some
initiatives like hey guys if this delete
it now they've already started with
someone that was a brightness stuff yeah
right
they I wouldn't be surprised they pull
you know like that week before launch
give you a taste alright um armor 2.0
and then it's like yo just for heads up
before shadow keep goes live you're
running around this you I don't have to
hold on to this old stuff it's gonna be
useless or it's not gonna have the same
effect you should trade it in for these
parts or whatever if there's some new
currency who knows but I think there
will be some sort of onboarding slash
transition nary phase when they probably
permit 2.0 cuz this is a lot of stuff to
get it yeah I mean we're gonna have new
stats on a character's to look at and
track and then we look over an old armor
it's not gonna help those at all so like
a piece of blue armor is probably gonna
have more stats than we've got now so I
mean if we're as we're leveling up
honestly it might just be like we're
clean slate it here we go
I just it's like if I knew I got nothing
from the old armor like I couldn't break
it down get anything from it I honestly
don't know cuz it seems the way it looks
like with armor 2.0 is like if you
unlock the ability to use say like
recovery 5 for example like the higher
recovery it seemed in my head it's just
like you pick it but it's always
available it's not like I have to go use
like I have to keep my 17 super mods or
something in case I need to use those
later so there's not like a currency
anymore with mods it's like it's like
inherent to just like the armor
selection energy piece itself so I'm
wondering I'd literally just have more
questions than answers the more I think
about it it's ridiculous so I always
thought that maybe be interesting I
don't know if this is again maybe
something they're kind of doing but I
always thought that destiny to like
armor modifications would do well with
like a Diablo style like lot system
where you have like a piece that has so
many different slots and that you can
like stack however many fit in that
block space on the weapon no I mean
maybe so like you get sort of like these
weird patterns so we're talking about
Diablo sockets and stuff like that yeah
yeah if you have a sockets yeah
interesting like that but mmm definitely
a possibility oh you gonna see how to
get our hand on this thing and they will
on board that will be the key yeah I
just want some clarification before it
happens and there is one little piece I
feel like when I mentioned for destiny
to will be live on Steam on that like I
swear they're describing that steam like
shadow keep live it sounds like and I'm
praying it's not like the verbage that I
keep seeing is like it's day and date
and I'm like you better let me move my
stuff over before laying employment we
we talked didn't we kind of talked a
little I keep seeing something somewhere
that like a little pre switch of so I
are like let me make sure it's there I
don't even care if I play I just want to
log in and be able to see my characters
but I can't hit a server or something
until the 17th play I just want to know
what's there so I'll be very curious
about this team so it's oh yeah we just
keeps piling these questions on and we
don't have answers yet so open thing but
the table did drop yesterday night thank
you to Cosmo we did get a chance to meet
that gentleman still always thought I
expect oh and I'm like he's easy to spot
a guardian Connie is definitely one of
the taller ones but they said you know
we've begun to see shadows lurking
around this season you know the moons
haunted everything like that so people
are working on triumph and they also
talked about the cheese a little bit so
but the big thing we got next week there
a little bit of we don't know it's like
couple of weeks iron banner is next week
so we've got July 23rd to July 30th
you've got your boost in Valor so if
you're working on Valerie sets for any
reason it's a good time to spend some
time in there for any reason and then of
course if you guys are working on the
quest path that you go through they say
they tweet some stuff a little bit but
not for this iron banner it's gonna be
for the next iron banner so some of
those we need like all the kills
whatever the steps are that we're slow I
think was the grenades people are having
trouble with
that will be tweaked I guess in the
final one so not yet but the big section
that I kinda wanted to get you guys
thoughts on this one or at least what
your interpretation of the verbage is a
guardian always pays their debts
it has part of season of opulence
Guardians are paying homage to the
previous adventures to earn some awesome
rewards some of us leveraged an exploit
in the tribute wall taking advantage of
callous generosity with some clever
character switching shenanigans to place
that free tribute over and over and over
this allowed some players it was great -
excuse me - skip the tribute experience
entirely making other players who had
done bounties and pledged large amounts
of their resources feel kind of irked we
will be using this glitch on July 30th
as we kicked out kick off solstice of
heroes as all of you know it is not our
policy to punish players who discovered
cheese's loot caves or workarounds in
the game if you took advantage of the
shortcut you can rest easy you won't be
marched in front of Cal's for sentencing
I love how this is all written by the
way it's great however you will not be
able to keep using all of your
ill-gotten rewards until you square up
things with callous hmm the tributes
place total will will now accurately
reflect tributes based on your accounts
if you use the exploit and this is the
one I want to know what you guys think
is the way I read this it could be
interesting because I know I helped
somebody do the cheese gonna be mad
because I didn't do I didn't get a
chance to the cheese I was like already
in it before I knew if you use the
exploit the number will update to the
properly reflected total number of
tributes you've actually placed the
activation and equipping of both the bad
juju catalysts and x marks the spot
emotes are also gated by your total
number of tributes placed bad juju will
not require you to to have 18 tributes
place for it to be used if you choose
your way to the catalyst or emote you
have some time to start placing legit
tributes before July 30th
so do you think another way I would read
this I want your thoughts like you're
you're not gonna be able to use the
emote or the catalyst if you choose it
is that the way you guys read it like
they're gonna deactivate those I think
you'll be able to use it up until they
reset it so you can it's big I feel like
what they're saying is that you can
basically use what you've gotten up
until they reset it to make sure that
you're squared away by the time they
reset it but if you haven't by then yeah
I think they're snatching that away from
me taking that they're taking the
catalyst away I I mean I don't know how
they're grayed out are they gonna grade
out like how they do with oh we've
played them over the place how you get
in jail with juju I don't know how I
don't know how it'll display but that's
certainly what it sounds like
it's like use the catalyst to make sure
that your 500 kills or whatever with the
catalyst and you don't equip it is that
gonna be unlocked if you get the 500
kills you even turn it on and they still
gonna grade out of if your tribute hauls
now I'm wondering how far they reach
with that like go back given themselves
some room to stretch it if they want
yeah I'm kind of like if you they won't
take your gun away but the catalyst
you'll have to really are they need to
shave y'all do you have a dunce cap at
the start of shadow keep like wings is
out there juju jail no it'd be perfect
you have a little bad juju skull just
floating around you is kind of a little
emo just like glaring at you constantly
cuz they way
splitter you dude you and you can't
touch it until you dislike yeah I think
the gun will not go away but the use of
the catalyst or the emote those the ones
you risk and I think they might leave
you so that's a big one that's the clear
up yeah you guys are gonna put some work
in or at least farm some things
screams actively get around logging in
right now farming taming up the
controller there you go as I said this
is funny this is this is a good enough
before we move on um a certain other
actually had wasn't mention the farm
mmm-hmm I thought I thought the hammer
was coming down on both also let me see
how they handle this they tweeted out
any direct references even the farm for
it genomics I just heard somebody else
like saying I think it's mixed maybe I
got enough comments on the video saying
I think it's fixed cuz I got dropped
orbit and maybe I'm confusing
yeah I'm wonder if they've like casually
tagged that in the background cuz I feel
like I have been getting kicked more and
more so yo chat later said Bungie needs
to make it a move that is just a
guardian eating the block of cheese and
drinking wine and called it I earned
this educated but you forever given a
permanent but you have to shame a move
from game shame shame shame shame my big
you have with it even though they get
killed but doing it well it'll be that
Ghost emo that like how
it's just like the projection of a piece
of cheese is that wrong there you go
gotta stay with a permanent cheese
emblem until you get squared away how do
you get that in love dude you don't want
to know you know what this life baby I
gotta get banned for a week for this
secret triumph tab don't do this the
food this could have yeah so yes enjoy
it while you can is all they will say to
you and usually and that's honestly one
of those things buns your husband he
said that be like hey games broken okay
you got it
well we're we're gonna we're gonna play
with it a little bit this time but we're
not taking it all the way we gotta say
real quick is that unlike some games
anthem that if you know explain their
game Bungie pull is playful with it and
it says they know what you're doing but
you know it's not gonna be one of those
situations and remember what happened I
didn't it was just you know it was crazy
so at least you know I like their
light-hearted humor with stuff and they
take responsibility it's a mistake on
their part and you know but obviously
gonna they're gonna you know do some
justice you know get things squared away
so III gotta give them they're for the
most part they're very cool when things
like this happen
I feel yep so you found something that's
broken
good job mm-hmm we'll fix it as soon as
we can Thanks when anthem had that joint
energy anaconda Blake really banned like
for using an in-game thing it's like and
it's honestly the thing about that that
was worse it's a PvE game you do nothing
but break the game for yourself
literally no pvp no implications of like
well this is gonna be too easy you're
making the game that one person make the
game easier for themself or they're
getting more loot for them it's like who
cares
I was always it's still a mistake in
their game yeah did want to shout out
movie the week though quick watch it
check it out
solo ribbon really haven't seen it after
put out like it was done during revelry
cuz you could have the buff and some
things were kind of broken this is the
first time post patch Wow it was backs I
don't want to say it's Baxley as the
gentleman who did it mmm and then
shortly after ISIL erage did it because
I think he probably used a similar strat
dude like to do it alone even during
revelry takes a lot of guessing like if
they were in there for 10 hours to get
reasonable attempts cuz you have to
guess on the eyes you absolutely have to
guess so just solo it at all that is
some hella work like that's all like oh
I'll solo night falls shattered Throne
zero raids boss solo like and Riven as
damn complicated as she is mm-hmm that
is like literally one in I don't even
know but that's yeah she wanted to shout
that one out cuz that is absolutely
longers I think I heard one of the
strats is like the hunter
it's the hunter punishing yeah something
don't know with mailing stuff right now
again some nice buff right now so do
what you got to do man but that I that
even with a buff like that soloing a
raid is next level like that's I don't
care what's going on that's next level
yeah but without trying to solo Kelly
but I think most people so low-calorie
would whisper was better so I don't know
if you could do it now mmm I'd be
curious to see ya whisper in the state
but yeah it's been a light couple of
news weeks but they do have more stuff
coming so we know you have questions
about cross same shadow keep new
character customization season I'm dying
and things we haven't even hinted at yet
yay the Sun won't be the time to get you
ready for another moon lunch and shout
out to Cosmo somewhere in his swabs
get something related to a cat in there
Ainge gave him a hard time and it's in
there now I don't know if it was not or
nobody noticed it at first but on that
bottom line next to the word shadow keep
that kama is a different color yes and
it links you to cats
hilarious yes still got it in there
shout out to colonize this cat work and
that one's actually hilarious nice so
yes I mean the table is pretty light
we've got some stuff going on I know
yeah you were all good just what did we
talk about the I'm guessing that for a
minute that's where I was that's where I
was going so okay guys make sure we get
that in yeah so if you guys haven't seen
they did the moon destination reveal
yesterday it's about a four-minute
viaduct talking about just bringing the
moon back into destiny we've heard
little things about I mean there was
previous talks I saw I was out there in
an interview or something like that like
destiny to can only get so big like it's
about a hundred gig right now on certain
consoles like bigger kids you keep
adding destinations like this could be
so I kind of have two questions on this
one for you guys as well open it for
discussion one do you guys think this
will be the last destination we get and
then to just what are you thoughts about
everything in that moon real like
thoughts about like how big it is what
it looks like what little floating stuff
is like I just want to know your overall
thoughts on that moon reveal quick
question define last destination we get
up doesn't need to like when I say
destination license it oh okay got you
get like more space of our queue how
much bigger can the game get is what I'm
getting after it lift scream go scream
um as far as the last destination we get
I really don't know because you're right
it is really really big but I think
there might be some way but they
reorganized the game too late
more content earlier maybe less relevant
sections through the whole playthrough
becoming maybe a little bit more
streamlined I don't know as the game I
would assume if they wanted to continue
to add they would have to do something
like that at a certain point
yeah like mean to you at this point like
you know something you can kind of I
don't want to say jump over but sort of
just move rapidly quickly through play
maybe more if you really really want to
but yeah as the moon looks great from
what I saw in the Vidak I like how
they're sort of revamping the the color
scheme of it and redness right and some
of those areas that you know you would
you kind of always hoped would have
something in them seem like they're
gonna be explorable now I know they
there was one lost sector in like that
central area where they helium filaments
arm was yes yeah things like that I
always like the moon so I mean I don't
know exactly what their I mean I don't
even know necessarily how big the moon
will be comparatively like I'm
envisioning something I'll you know like
along the size of like maybe like a Mars
you know like they say twice what the
moon used to be mm-hmm twice what the
moon used to be think of it probably
something remember ones right in d1 like
four major zones would likely in the
underground basically yeah an expansion
itself they're saying it's a pretty big
like rising iron that's pretty big
that's wise to know comparatively you
know same scale you there men scream is
back yeah I don't know what that was
maybe it was my internet but what was
the last thing you heard me say sorry we
was talking about Muay Thai massage guys
yet
well and what was your final question I
can't remember either is this just
though I mean just everything about the
vibe of the Moon revealed is kind of
your thoughts because you got everything
from you've got the big castle you know
it's twice as big as the moon
potentially before like they're
implementing lost sectors you got the
little floating bodies like just all the
stuff about it oh yes that was the
floating bodies yeah I don't know what
that that whole deal is no I I mean you
know probably a good area for some lore
exploration for Harris lutely
but I mean it looks certainly like
humans
seems like a head and forearms and they
definitely seem taken what humans you're
talking about with forearms but continue
Lord correction himself humans you know
forearm six legs don't worry about a
scream I deal with it every about it you
take that it's cried you keep pushing
them I mean it definitely looks taken to
me you're not so who you know really all
I could speculate there was like an
alien in some movie where he just had
big arms like that about that yeah I
mean that's really I yes what you get
yeah that's all I mean obviously the
hive and the taken are somewhat closely
related as far as lore goes I'm not as I
mean I love the lore I'm never always
the best speculator of lore fine it
seems like they would be something you
know the moon taken maybe uh maybe mixed
in together I'm kind of curious it's
like what that big thing on necess was
that that big zone that underdeveloped
zone under the
that seemed to have some taken in it too
uh you know I'm kind of curious about
that because I thought that maybe me
something with shadow keep maybe some
sort of like branch mission you know and
I don't know yeah yeah there might be
something later we got to see I mean I
mean I definitely sort of the the
four-minute fired acting really one
thing about mines they really do a great
job of promoting and this is cool to see
especially free from Activision how they
handle and I thought this was really
good and um first thing we got a wean
even talk about our girl Paris Dublin
bubbling touch and stuff and he feels
this weird gun that looks like has
relics of her old team on it or
something he's always in a tunnel
somewhere yeah you know I just need to
hear all the crazy connection talk
that's what I'm I'm for that connection
talk and I'm all I want to know if
because of the fun relationship
hurricane if she references the home
he does they yeah you know she's got a
reference to homies we know she ain't no
big hearted person but you know get your
rock off my mat was like classic style
ends it's one of my favorite line and
him stealing her champagne it's always
fun games between him he what he had or
her grapes but I wanted to see like you
know how she acknowledged that but
enough about that
Kade was definitely the haand to her
lair yes you know the thing is I want to
see you from what we saw the locales
look don't you know it's the moment it's
a more visit it like you said scream
they've read that ominous that Tao is
just ominous the twice the size of it I
remember that part of the map on the
right side where you would walk past
that structure but now they saying you
can go in that whole thing doctors know
that really big Thomas I excitement you
know so it's just not like I know a lot
of people gonna give it bungees reusing
assets again and okay fine but this is
look cool I don't care what you say this
thing looks cool to me the dead car
or forearm humans whatever we call it
it's like yo octopus but they're gold
man
and I got a theory My dear ear I
literally I have no laws shot to mind
i'ma hit up my pocket know the truth but
I'm just speculating night they keep
going on this nightmare thing theme a
sing your fears and we've already got
comp confirmation that older people
we've already defeated we're gonna have
to fake zingle crota hints of Oryx I'm
Sam I'm gonna go I'm gonna go like it'll
be dope if we got like a little little
bosses and stuff like that or we get all
dr. Wily's castle all the bosses that be
at least about five menagerie Oh like
that literally is that this is addicts
dream he's all about boss fight so we
were talking about it I was like yo
listen there's a strong possibility so
we gotta see what's going on with that
what's the true sauce
I'm not feeling taken just yet I hope
not but uh you know I'm nice if it is it
is but I get the sense is something
different but it's nightmare thing seems
different
I want to see where they go with it and
um the last thing I was gonna say like
just in general like um the dark guard
like I want to know if we get more
closure with her original team because
she alludes to suffering right
she allude to you know their suffering
and being tormented people are being
tormented so I gotta see what's going
the moves gonna be late they talk about
the fall and got a got a set up shop
they get a run in for retreating is
looking at but um yeah this is this
dating that catch or whatever I can't
wait I can't wait this is exciting to me
I want to see the moon is I didn't
realize how much I missed them all until
I saw this be I'm gonna let you go to
each other I mean you guys are hitting
all good things so I mean for me on the
moon you've got the giant castle looks
huge Oh like when they get closer and
closer to that spire it looks like quite
massive
so that looks amazing the keep set up to
that that's probably gonna be its own
new zone or potentially part of the
Hellmouth but it's it looks so much
bigger than just the Hellmouth for sure
and that's what I was getting to so we
know the rain is on the black garden how
on earth they connect the lure to that I
have no clue
yeah and I really hope they do connect
it somehow because if it's just an
arbitrary here's a raid like not cool
but the dungeon
if the dungeon is in the new red castle
keep thing they got going on I'm gonna
be living in there you know where I'll
be you go ahead if you may hide you sit
now shout out that nighters mmm ed
hammock Guardian Conn fees involved in
making a new dungeon and I'm wondering
because a little rotating they look like
a forest trap they're like the spiky
rotating cylinders that you see and
they're kind of moving up and down that
still looks like it's on the moon it
doesn't look like it would be a raid
thing so that feels like that would be
like a dungeon jumping puzzle mechanic
type thing not a not a raid mechanic
jumping puzzles so I'm like this could
be fun mm-hmm but yeah it was really
cool they took like most places I mean
yeah they took the one section on the
moon where you like hey there's this
little building and you're like I can go
in here and pick up a chest now it's a
whole lost sector before you would
actually go down and you know wake up
the hive and then no I mean I'm looking
forward to it I think between Armour 2.0
the moon coming back can be unpopular
and I think the moon is gonna be sizable
the underground like they real it they
would throw a read a tear I mean yeah
they may have used like geometry of the
moon but they went through and look like
they're retexture to real it just about
everything in there gave it a different
feel because if you look in there to
even talk about just like the feeling of
like over saturating the lighting and
then changing that up for the new one to
give it a difference just a different
completely different aesthetic and then
we've got the hive but are these like
the Sauron touched hive with like the
red across their face because they all
look they all look to have a different
colour scheme to and they're not just
like grey hive right they have that like
the acolytes specifically you see it in
the videos like they have like the red
face
something's up like they
I don't know if they're gonna have
different abilities kind of like the
frozen hive would be slightly tweaked
and we got like the snipers there I'm
curious what we see but yeah we've got
possibly some different hive but yeah a
big dr. Wily's boss room situation I
don't see it happening maybe that maybe
those the bosses are gonna be like so I
guess here's the question would it be a
letdown if those were like the what were
they in the top barons like the barren
adventures if the box issues I can't pay
me oh I'm okay with it I mean I go crazy
but I would love the other thing you
know saying yeah I don't know how again
I have no idea how they'll implement the
whole thing maybe it's the story we go
through and fight but yeah I'm kind of
curious where all the bosses are gonna
come in because there's quite a few we
saw quite a few quite like every strike
area seems to be redone so absolutely I
want to see that phone call what was the
one I can't remember god you used to be
able to get his crown as a helmet if you
were a warlock that redone it had the
big ball spinning ball well there are
phases of solar our can Boyd Lake yeah
me luck I can't remember if it's being
something like that in video yep yeah oh
you're talking about yeah so longing
that nightfall was a pain in the butt
that was a tough one tough one
absolutely I'm excited that I'm excited
I'm definitely more confident with each
bit of information when you guys think
the full-blown marketing push way which
lied now we know it's what September 2
months out basically to muffs out so
when do we think we start getting them
good acts them them twitch duo deals
depends on I mean I'm sure it's probably
gonna be close to ready I don't know if
they play the game of you drop this
trailer will drop this trailer like do
they play it against cuz I mean you got
Borderlands Link's Awakening Monster
Hunter world you have a lot coming out
around that time are they gonna try and
like make sure and get their pieces I
mean they're gonna probably have their
schedule
I would probably see for them they're
gonna have a push for steam in and of
itself
you are they're gonna have that probably
paired with something for new light I
could see that a couple weeks before
like get ready destiny 2 is coming free
I could probably see that coming to
probably no more than two weeks I can
almost see it starting in September Wow
cuz they've waited like I don't know
it's like the expansion I know will be
bigger new light state is gonna have its
own push some of those things will be
closer and stay Diaz later when it
releases but yeah I could see they've
done everything really close to the
seasons but I guess for the expansion
jerk if I might see it sooner that might
go on in there a little sooner I don't
know they could do it anyways what do
you think the the push they might go I
think you're gonna see to see a lot of
stuff like honor about Labor Day like
around that and you know end of end of
August early September
okay so much later okay we we differ I
would ask to see what are you thinking
next week I'm thinking like a latest top
of August I mean I remember like
forsaking stuff he was getting that even
former breakdowns like almost like a
full month two months ahead of time
they've already technically talking
about shadow keep right now literally
given us Vioxx right now they say that
the pushes started already
yeah in the push like this there's no
doubt mama this is critical for them on
their own we gonna be getting trip they
dream they've been drip-feed know a lot
earlier I mean this polygon article
where Noseworthy in the loop you got I'm
saying like I could see another big
outlet look I think it's gonna come down
to what happened last time which was arm
normally before used to be gaming for
right the game before get these big
blowout will get the information I think
it's gonna be whoever wins don't getting
right shadows I'm gonna do this exam
informers gonna cover shadow keep I
think they're probably gonna take
Borderlands 3 if they haven't already
it maybe in last time a fiber or
fireteam chat and IGN is he wants to pad
um mostly the last big one was a last
wish or something like that as far as a
Goliath yeah I know they have a one push
for sure I know they got
they might be some other entity bigger
outlet was um was in control of it so I
think is gonna be you know a bit more
gonna be high whoever's gonna get it and
yeah I think we're gonna start getting
they're gonna start trickling stuff and
like you say cuz think about you forget
about the game itself which has a ton of
new content and a ton of new things
they're gonna implement we've got all
the things you said
we got stadia we've got crossfade we've
got bad on that ending going now over
there you know I'm saying this thing
like you've got huge transitionary
things you gotta give people a ton of
time to get ready to make sure it's done
right because you know people gonna
there's gonna be up that that fact that
needs to go out right hey I got this
what happened oh my god but but I
previewed it I I need to pre-order I
already owned you already know you they
gonna get inundated they've got to be so
ahead of the game with this so I say now
we in it this is very early drip-feed
top of August first two weeks they're
gonna get that market and bliss going
they're gonna get long big on really and
they need to I mean let's be honest boy
lands are still out there to you know
Monster Hunters out there and all these
other games and they got to what do you
guys think about sort of as a question
is I mean as far as like another Bungie
livestream do you think they're gonna do
have they announced another one and when
do you think if they haven't when do you
think they would do another one so they
haven't announced one I know that for
sure I'll announce when yeah what do you
think you think they'll do one
definitely everything we got to get the
armor 2.0 break we've got to get um
they're gonna probably do maybe like two
I would say maybe want to agree kind of
like the old for I mean this one I get
it this was the other Activision format
so who knows but what remember how they
would give you like a little piece this
is how armors gonna work and yeah this
is whatever whatever then whatever
redacted surprise we're gonna get I
think most likely we gonna get either
some mode some new activity or some
returning mode that they're holding on
to because these guys out at the
summit's now right shout to the Queen
and she came back right we're clean and
stuff a lot of people are
at these um summits that are getting the
experience now you don't mean these
content creators so wait for next week
yeah they're chatting a little bit with
you we can't yet do that sir we gotta
stay professional we can't
scuse me
excuse me did you did you get it did you
answer did you ask them this what did
they say excuse me rocket is questions
like how confident do you feel about
right what are your feelings about what
you have in the future are you excited
Alex were there any moments of drastic
surprise as any new I'm gonna go for
emotional questions I need to do a kid
go there you go tell me what you saw but
I want to know how you felt yeah agreed
black wings out there I was thinking
about a street maybe a long viaduct I
could see if I talked I can see that
yeah I can see a couple of I talks to be
like hey check out this viaduct going
with the table they'll usually drop
those on like a Wednesday and then cover
some info on like a Thursday in the tuam
if they don't want to do a full stream
cuz Street is pretty big get up let me
take some effort and like the Vai talks
a little more curated especially if they
want like a specific message when it
comes to that and I think they've also
kind of steer away from here's the
Destiny what destiny one fashion game
lockout and right back lockout turn
right back well but yeah I can
definitely see I still would like to see
one stream because just cuz I don't at
least but I think the Vioxx would
probably work a little better for
specific explaining hey this is Armour
2.0 this is like any army you got right
now going for it like just some
clarification on things that is like
nobody's interpreting a stream it's like
it's a curated Vidocq this is the
information we want so one or two of
those might be good downs got a good
question yeah I was gonna get to it so
yeah have you guys looked through the
vitac enough to see basically what I
would guess potentially either maybe
it's a raid boss or the main boss like
what do you guys think the kid do you
think the campaign on the Ray
for one our gonna tie and what do you
think the bosses are going to be like
cuz the main thing they say is like she
like she goes down she awakens these
nightmares for what eros does however
and whatever do you think we're actually
fighting something to hive or do you
think it's something kind of different
what are you guys feeling
hmm so what what do you think we're
gonna fight in either the raid the
campaign or both
I'll jump in I'm legit stumped because
the easy thing to me in my opinion is
like Sabbath home yeah you know saying
or you know things that we kind of know
about heard you know returning but
there's a lot going on in destiny right
now right you know there's a lot more
wise going on and I don't think we're
gonna get drift to stuff resolution but
we still gotta figure out when is Aldrin
involving himself with anything all
right
so the other question is I'm curious I'm
gonna learn a lot how Aris is introduced
because is it going to be a situation
like taking King where she when she
pulls up at the tower you know I'm
saying or whatever it was and you know
it's like you know I Corps was there but
is that vanguard council right of what's
gonna happen you know um you know let's
see about that or is it a situation
where it's kind of like maybe she just
reaches out to a core or one person on a
slide or just the Guardian you know
saying but she has the relationship with
the Vanguard so you know I'm curious I
think how she's introduced is gonna tell
us a lot as far as in game as far as the
boss is concerned man I mean we're
hearing what black garden already right
confirmed in it in what capacity days
did they stay rain is in black garden
tomb I know okay so okay so if that's
confirmed I'm all messed up because
wasn't that vex before that was yeah
that was vexed doing black garden but
then he had the heart of the black
garden but yeah that was taking control
me minotaurs and yeah it's it's just a
nomad
a blob yeah so it's just like tip I am
legit stomped I do not
know where this is going and I'm very
curious I'm gonna give it up to scream
buddy what do you think well I
definitely think the campaign is gonna
tie into the raid just because they see
Isis wanting to do a lot more of that so
like and so I think that's gonna be yeah
a thing I think I think it has to this
is what I think is gonna keep saying I
think when like I feel as though her
story the end of whatever happens here
the culmination of whatever happens here
is not more I don't know if it's gonna
have anything necessarily to do
specifically with aldrin but it has to
at least it's definitely gonna in my
opinion lead into that arc somehow yeah
because we've seen too much where it's
like what do you just want us forget
about all of that like he woke up on a
thing like what's going on there
talk about a scream cuz I'm saying like
if she comes in the tower or happens
yeah cutty I'm sorry you might cut out
again yeah I'm so sorry I don't know
what no go for it
no I yeah I feel like it has to has to
weave itself into that some way that's
kind of what I think the purpose of it
might be what is actually just to weave
the plot that direction like you
discover something and you know there a
hidden plot you know the reason why
these things are happening something
along those line I mean from a writer's
perspective that's where I would go with
it the whole thing with the black garden
know that I mean off yeah it does if it
was the heart of the black garden was
such a nondescript thing I always sort
of harken back to there was this one
little I don't know if it was in the
grip it wasn't yeah I was in the
grimoire of like one of the grimoire
cards from d1 where it talks about this
these it's a three-way conversation
going on you kind of get the sense that
I think it was in the warmind grimoire
like what are the voices talking is a
war mind
we're not you know we can assume it's
Rasputin but it could have been another
one
I think it's Rasputin though man it's a
conversation it's having with another
like godly entity Oh about the traveler
whew
so it's like these three sort of you
know like superhuman entities or like
two having a conversation about another
and I've always sort of like I thought
they were gonna return to the black
garden a long time ago yeah like I
thought I was actually gonna be
something in d1 so yeah I don't really
know I you know you could always kind of
make the assumption that it was that
it's not vex I mean and maybe that
clears up some stuff but that's a pretty
big assumption you know you know I mean
that they ever actually talked about in
d1 is was the heart of the black garden
is specifically like like vex God or was
it just something that they worshiped i
I just remember find a whole bunch of it
I was like it was pretty vague honestly
to mine I feel like it was big enough
where maybe it was something else like
maybe the the heart of the black are not
a vex thing something they were guarding
I don't know you know who knows that's
where you can really get speculative
with them there's a lot of different
ways you could certainly take up the
plot of d1 d2 currently I've always and
I think I might have said this somewhere
I don't really know exactly what I was
talking about but maybe it was just with
Yui that like I've always hoped that
rather than they've introduced so many
threads yes you know I hope this is a a
wine that they're the ultimate goal is
to wind them together now yeah that and
still introduce new threads but at a
certain point you go I
I got enough here to make a sweater
let's let's get to knit you know yeah
yeah put some connections in that you'll
move in that was the right Daddo even
asked he's like we're gonna move this
like movie forward yeah I say if they do
do another stream I hope they have
someone like that like yeah he was on
fire he
that was great and I loved that specific
question maybe that's where I'm thinking
about it like maybe I talked with
somebody about that interview after that
was one of the questions actually not
even as a big as a big Maine lore guy
enjoying it but you know I really
enjoyed that question because there's a
lot there and it's and it's certainly
interesting a ton of interesting things
be what you got man what's your theories
okay so for me I have no idea how to
connect the two first I don't know if
they do my question is how we get there
like I feel like hopefully the story has
a connection of like hey there's this
thing there's some like mastermind
puppeteer whatever is causing these
nightmares I think is probably not what
we face in the campaign or at least I'm
hoping not because I loved how like
regicide was a mission when we fought
the big version of orcs there's one
frame in the viaduct when they show the
raid and it's a picture I can't send it
to anybody right now here let's see if I
can actually open this thing all right
so I'm gonna put this in chat so you
guys can see it that is a frame from the
viaduct and there's one little image and
what that looks like if it's not like a
tree it looks kind of like a taking
enemy with like a whole bunch of
tentacles around it because it has that
color the black and kind of a whitish
look yeah and my only wondering is that
the other thing everybody's wondered
about for a little while is Korea or
however you say it
whoa oryx's other sister Rai Rai Rai
right so I'm wondering if like savathun
still might be the big triangle ships
and I don't know it's a Korea or a qu RI
is how it's written if she might be
because she is now taken she could have
enough motivation and power to be able
to do and cause some of these nightmares
and work through the hai of that way
that would be kind of cool no idea if
it's even possible well that would be
kind of a way to kind of have a weird
connection still plant the seed because
I think the triangle ships are
still d3 but to build on some of what
we've got and I would love to see
something along the lines of like Eris
is looking at a map and somebody sets a
gun on it and she looks up and it's
older and I would just lose my mind oh
good I was just about to ask you
eligible what's your over/under on
actually being in this expansion or
anymore season of the undying I I feel
like they want to save him with his
sister with Mara whenever she comes back
and she's doing some grandiose plan for
or against the triangle ships and stuff
like that I would like to see them move
him forward I would love that to she's
like she's in the tower working on
somebody and somebody just like kind of
like walks in and just completely
clueless because he doesn't know and be
like cuz she doesn't know him either I
think that would be an interesting
dynamic because she's been off doing her
thing for five years and not sure about
this whole Aldrin guy so I think that
would be kind of a cool way for them to
meet and she's like hey I found this guy
and then I Corps loses her like I could
like build it up like Ike or loses stuff
like Cevallos holding her back she's
charging her Nova bombs the cauldrons
overload like I don't know what you
don't know who you think I am
if you want to start shadow keep yeah
you'd lose my mind if I saw like
whatever games like I don't think we
will go to that level but I think that
would have this would be a time for Eris
coming back especially if she's like the
vendor on the moon to have some way to
bring him in but also like because you
could actually have that as your other
storyline because you have the campaign
that you the storyline with Eris
obviously but I also would worry if the
oldrin would take away from Eris yeah I
am more displaced
heiresses their true focus and I'm like
no they're gonna play Jason and yeah
that's why part of me as much as I think
I want of course we won't all just be
there no my gut says they'd probably
save him from this deal because like you
said her coming back Marla coming back
is a big deal that's a big deal and um
we already seen you know her guardian
cop she she she's a professional you
know and they do yeah
about promoting her and those characters
really don't have a relationship again
not saying it's impossible that those
who won't you know not me but you know
I'm I think they probably want to make
it more about her and the threat and
probably take it from there but hey if
you got some dialogue laughs fun boy oh
gee you know I wouldn't be opposed you
know he rolled up in the tower I will be
upset I just sit back and grab the
popcorn man oh yeah I just want to see
Zavala I Cora and I chorus face
yeah just literally trying not to just
instant Nova bond and into oblivion it's
like I don't care if I blow up the tower
I've got to kill him like and you know
your father would give the viola
prophetic I told you so repercussions of
your actions stuff I don't know if it'd
be that he'd be holding her back from
trying to get her you'd be like no Mike
or you're better than this don't do it
he's a guard you know he doesn't know
yeah Warcraft 3 level cinematic I would
love to see something like that like
that and again that's where I think that
scale of like holy crap I think that's
when you I think you do a d3 I think
that's where that falls yeah Mar the
space Doritos Sabbath hoon if all like a
new race those saw somebody's thumbnail
I'm not gonna specifically call it out
oh but it's got pyramid ship enemies
literally on the thumbnail it's like
armor 2.0 reveal a pyramid ship enemies
and I'm going I don't feel like that's
crap but that's just yeah d3 that's d3 I
mean to me everything
since d2 ended we beat Gaul and the
light was expecting it has been in order
of expand of expansions last season so I
don't I think that is literally deep
when they we have to deal with that
threat yeah I guess the only thing that
somebody could speculate is that the
void or whatever they're called like the
race from that first concept art of the
four races in the fifth level of the
triangles they are kind of these black
like wispy type care
right people might be speculating that
the floating bodies are those but I
think that's definitely some clickbait
but yeah you guys got any more thoughts
on what's to come and oh scream you're
on here if you got any other opinions
theories you always got some some more
knowledge bombs to drop yeah I mean a
lot of it comes from just you know
having to write a number of scripts and
film scripts ha ha ha you kind of hope
that they're making the same sort of
assertions assertions that you're making
in your own mind as far as where the
lore goes
I kind of agree that like it would be
really fun if you were to introduce
oldrin it would be sort of like a like
you know lat what'swhat's the gun last
word yes last word like a last word drop
on the table at the end of like some
major like plot culmination and then you
know he says what line and it cuts to
black like that so that's your tease for
whatever like yeah I go through three
season passes we get nothing about him
and we're just sitting there for nine
months like I feel like we're gonna see
that shot like I feel like been shot if
if you see him it will be something like
that I don't think right I don't think
he's gonna get introduced in this DLC I
think there might be because they are
gonna focus on her but question Oh
question please I think sorry the rope
we also forgetting about a nut like you
made a good point about all these
threads right all these threads do got
going on what about drifter and the
Vanguard decision oh yeah well do we get
the culmination of that choice I think I
um I don't think you're gonna see that
for a minute
yeah or whatever I mean I would agree
with you however they're progressing as
far as d2 or d3 but yeah it's gonna be I
think you're gonna actually have to see
a guy from Mercury Osiris first oh I
think there'll be some return to him
before you see anything
drifter I don't and I know that that
might feel like completely out of left
field but that's a character that is
important in some way did you say that
again character he's a time traveler
he's got to be important there's no
character more inner woven with the vex
lore and you're gonna have to flush that
out and I think if you're returning to
the black garden in some way it's gonna
have to have something to do with the
facts so there's gonna you know it's
like if they don't do it it's it's weak
storytelling and that's not them yeah
but we got a I got a I got those Raynham
oh please yeah okay I guess yeah yeah
hey oh no all I was gonna say is
somebody was saying when it comes to the
season of the undying
somebody was wondering like the specific
tie-in to the vex and the graphic that
they have at Guardian con it was like
redacted redacted redacted but the first
season was a picture of a goblin so
that's where then comes from a picture
of a goblin objects
oh so that graphic is out there people
tweeted it from Guardian con but yeah it
was from one of their streams or
something like that like little things
they did on stage but I was waiting in
line I looked over and it was like three
of the seasons were redacted and then
the first one was of X so that makes
sense that would make sense to me as far
as like a storyteller like I would want
to return to that you know and just
maybe give it a little bit more I mean
flush it out a little bit more give it a
little bit more credit because you know
mercury is ozone but do we go there you
know like maybe here and around about
coldest act whatever um no you're right
you right man I'm with you now which is
care I mean I again I'm really hoping
but I guess says keep it keep it in
perspective expectations long with that
I think we still may have a while you
know I mean it is vexed but I just I'm
worried because Eris is such a dominant
character in hive lore that I can't see
them playing with other figures around
because she herself hold your own you
know I'm saying oh yeah yeah yeah for
sure that's the only reason cuz all
these other things you're saying connect
it connects Lorelei's everything you're
saying connects things in the back so no
again I just I'm curious you know she
even with taken Kings sheet to the very
end and you know would we beat Oryx you
know she she's holding the sword she's
doing thing you know I'm saying like
she's always in the mix you know there
she's got a little bit of mysteriousness
with herself I mean yeah she helps us
but you know there's still some things
with her that's on a little bit of the
biggest yeah ambiguous slash maybe told
inside we don't know so you know I like
Miss America I act like Eris is this
this paragon of virtue that you know so
motives to so I'm very curious about it
I'm excited this is this is a good one
this is at least should move things
forward for hopefully that other stuff
so yeah a little bit Ortiz's or
somewhere in these seasons they start
teasing the other ships we're doing
question yeah The Drifter we like what
if it was the season of oldrin like I
mean you bring it season of The Prince
and then we got rosy rosy hazel and shad
just dropping bombs like what when Kyra
turns out to be playing everyone and
she's actually learning to take the
taken power let this be an i-told-you-so
Osiris tyrant of x1 my dream season view
season of Osiris trials comes back and
once yeah man that I would be so
thankful if they really wanted to blow
the doors open on an expansion that
would be it yeah that's how you do it
man get him a black man restore that it
was stalled my warlock to his glory
where he needs to community blow up
most powerful car I just did the same
for a teen quest no it's a lot of fun
with that
mm-hmm dope quest by the way don't that
you should be able to replay that strike
that's an amazing mission I wish that
you could like if you unlocked and be
like hey I want to go back or at least
for daily missions like how they unlock
the ace of spades though should be like
thrown in
sometimes yeah yeah always should be
repeatable so what's up man welcome
welcome late a couple of guys join us
towards the tail-end I definitely don't
want to go back because the the new like
free to play is gonna let you do that
very first mission from cosmodrome
correct is there any but well everybody
have the option to go back and do that I
hope whatever way I can get to do that
I'm definitely gonna go but honestly you
could go probably play like just by I'm
gonna make a new random account on Steam
you could probably go get destiny for
free and do that yeah yeah they just
feel kind of weird like it wouldn't
attached anything though cuz I don't
know if world ready to go back and play
it would be cool though I just kind of
want to go in and just you know troll
around in there again you always looking
for secrets you want to break the map
and go back and so yeah that's created
chaos we love it you guys got anything
else today I think we've speculated a
lot of stuff and looking forward to the
fall obviously it's kind of light for
stuff right now so just kind of getting
your grind on or your farm on depending
on what you're doing yes sir that's
about all I got so this is kind of we'll
wrap it we are about two and a half
hours so it's probably a fair time I was
the guests always great times will
scream tell everybody where they can
find you we appreciate having you on
always a pleasure sir drop it drop it
the Nuggets and knowledge and everything
on us we always appreciated but where
they make idea what do you got going on
what are your plans for it is a future
and that's how it's perfect that's
exactly what's going for a little
exploits that you can do is often as I
can
nice trying to curate as much of the the
raid secrets reddit as I try to if you
ever have a good one a good reddit
thread I would go check that out but
that's neither here nor there you can
find me at Wilhelm if you type in
Wilhelm scream destiny on YouTube or
Wilhelm with a one W il he1 em scream
you'll find me on YouTube and the same W
il h e1 m underscore scream on twitter
know
me on there and thank you guys again so
much for having me on tonight there's a
lot of fun always brother always been
good to have you back but up yeah so
yeah we asked Iman in a minute man we
got we got to reach out to always a good
time and you know how we get to talking
so good that and also appreciate your
support as well like you're a good
content creator your damn self you
always teach me stuff I find out about
even though you can do this all right
cool scree what another web and try my
best try my best
yeah yes yes allude to you to the
channel and everything you're doing and
in the growth and then I also again for
the support because you definitely
appreciate you out there for us I love
it you're the guys who i watch so thank
you really appreciate it back at you so
kognito sir what do you got coming any
fanciness for the sunday times just yeah
we had some fanciness but then we got
some fanciness reschedule so you know
this is all whole right now I'm still
actually formulating as it goes so
tuning things I don't even know we're
gonna hit go and be all right guys let's
talk what are we doing I would do that
to you yeah seriously
that's a last day I got I got a head act
I sell there but that's a little bit
yeah it will be I'll or podcast will be
there Sundays everyone porn p.m. every
Sunday is the Lord's Day I'm a podcast
YouTube channel please tune in and it
will be a fun show I know some of the
topics already have some great topic
we're gonna talk about what's going on
in the industry some fun fun discussions
some passionate disagreements might
happen so like every to always you know
you know wit Lord is gonna take sides
with another Lord for whose knees yeah
there's gonna be bending knee segments
is lot of these this is like random I
was like I know you guys cuz I've been
on before and you guys are really cool
you organized that everybody has their
point in the round table
mmm-hmm it would probably be honestly
controlled chaos like if you work the
round table but don't give everybody a
preview like everybody keep your own
topic hidden be kind of a like a secret
one like for you guys to see GUI
and I'll be crazy I was think about that
what we got to go it's just like we
can't let a dick get you out of control
for the Attucks is problem Oh
salute oh yeah that's my babe
does he get going he's easy to rile up
what he's passionate about son so yeah
the passion is like strong amongst all
also in every way I appreciate it it's
great can't script that stuff it's just
everybody's going back and forth some of
the lines and that's kind of the you
guys are legit I mean you're all gamers
we've all been around the block for a
little while and then it's like you guys
have those moments and then within the
same podcast cuz just like ours they can
go along you guys have some awesome real
just down-to-earth like legit cool not
like it goes both ways like if you guys
haven't listened to iron Lord podcast
check them out like please like show
some support there subscribe to the
channel find them on your audio they
will fill your ears for a good time with
some awesome entertainment if you're
gamers especially if you lean a little
more green than blue we lead a little
green but to be honest we believe we
don't have more Nintendo yeah man it's
been a struggle that's actually real
quick that's like one of my greatest
predictions ever it's just a success of
the Nintendo switch and I remember being
laughed at you know like like 10 you
know a bunch of IOPS ago I mean just
come laugh that like this is a failure
what are they doing and just to see the
success continued and me coveted there
every week we saw but I chest out like
the little engine that could did it it
is just fun so yeah there will be some
switch topics for sure it's definitely
gonna be switched out so it's been good
man I mean give me a breath a little
while - I just gotta play breath a wild
one first and salute the Vagabond oh hey
say it was a good last one good I'll pee
this past week thing about and also real
quick man yeah also check us out
Lords of gaming that man please if not
any type of attention to these articles
we've got some guys really
good work we had Josh reading it on here
before on the last word he's fantastic
as far as destiny order
we've got rosy haze aka dizzy because
that's under his bike school buddies
down but dizzy the editor-in-chief man
tremendous articles addict training you
know the list goes on condors Condor if
you're an overwatch guy you like that
kind of stuff he's got fantastical
we just got retro stuff for my boy big
jerseys we've got a lot of different
pockets and then obviously you know you
come to me like I'm you know for destiny
content and that's the article just got
one up right now on Alma 2.0 a lot of
the points I reiterated and so please
every retweet every like of just
checking out the article really helps us
helps us to grow to brand law it's a
gaming dotnet check it out man that's
all yeah I'm done marketing now
marketing so good absolutely that's what
these are for so and this for me do you
guys know where to find me right here
whether it's on YouTube Twitter twitch
it's about this you guys know where to
find the cheetah half the time talking
to the ninja or a split in the ninja in
my backpack I'll jump in that PvP
backpack with you it's cool man who his
own TV yeah I've been watching him
screen you have a picture of a cheetah a
ninja riding a cheetah because we wanted
to do that actually I should say we
would shout outs about bad graphic god
who did the last word artwork as a joke
he said no is what is going on right now
on screen looks I would buy that t-shirt
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you know maybe we get the votes go
look how many people be like these are
my friends there's one of Joe there you
go yeah
there's a lot of jokes that I have to
basically nip straight in the butt
because a lot of questions I had to
shoot it's just pretty much just gonna
say if you guys haven't caught my
schedule seven stages of grief video
that one was fun to put together do more
of that please more of - yes right
that's part of like I like this angry
eaters joke EEE
like everything is not analytic with
Professor e Bob Ross of Destiny stuff
that you see in a video like he is all
about funny bro like he's mad hang out
with this man is man it's hilarious just
listen so when he's doing videos like
this this is it a part of personality I
don't see so I love her wait you know
what your best window yeah and we got to
the pause screen when was the one waist
like you're pleading oh the bargaining
yeah the bhagavad me oh yeah I was like
it was trying to throw the Valkyrie
spear like down a hallway and it just
what it doesn't do crap when match game
is on so it's like come on come on you
know you wanted I come on come on never
mind thank you like yeah it's just like
yeah just and then there was one point I
was trying to go through and I had like
six different emotions with one little
like after death was just like oh then
like slaying my keyboard I'm like I'm
done it's like maybe I can figure this
I'm like going through everything in
like 30 seconds it's all it's all over
like everything and that's like if you
guys ever catch me on stream like you
guys will get to see some of those
attempts live I like it I put the video
out when I did the this week's like I
did a nightfall with like the high
roller loadout and somebody I was summer
who commented I played with her before
she's a cool follower and she was just
like hey where's the one where you died
two laser beams and I was like Shh
sometimes I'll throw the outtakes in
there but that was one where was like it
was they like perfectly clean run going
through like heavy ammo was drop into
the final boss room and it's true
probabilities where you have the lasers
ever worked yeah the final one you have
the upper tier and the two lower tiers
yes and I can be able to choose him it's
on the
right side and there's like the little
block that are blocked strategy it's
like you can basically like mess with
his like passing by hiding behind this
block and I just like I move unlike the
laser i watch it fade away and then I
move out to shoot when the laser came
right back and heal me as like and it
was like a perfect run all the way up I
was like cuz that boss run is brutal
because you have the three rooms and if
you die even at the very end when he has
a millimeter health you're back at the
start of all three wrong so like that
whole run is shot cuz now it's time
points ammo it's all gone so stuff like
that you guys will see like the real
versions of late and that's what a lot
of people commented was like hey it's
like I know I typically struggle doing
solo stuff it's nice to see you know
somebody as well as like you guys have
no idea how much I actually do like some
videos will take me like five six seven
eight hours just to have a damn good run
if it's like like when it was whisper
you like the amount of time to put in to
learn that things so that video is as
calm as it was a lot of effort just a
lot of time so no probably respected it
yeah big time because it's like you
showed a human element again that's what
the ever that regular guy needs to see
tonight okay okay now don't feel this
bad cuz I know he's got some struggle to
get there but you still get there and
then you break it down in a way that
someone a common that may struggle with
certain things can get there and that is
great keep it up man love that stuff
from you yeah somebody described their
like yeah it's like you're a lot better
than me there's one point they described
like corkscrewing their controller and I
was like what do you oh you're actually
like ripping your controller in half and
I was just like you got to work on some
anger issues at that point but yeah
doesn't people keep the controllers you
still need them letting you slam your
keyboard in half then well we all
understand but that's all we got so
sorry the long-winded outros here but
always a good time but scream thank you
for coming on it's awesome thank you
everybody for being in chat today next
week little preview we do have it
confirmed now travel things happen but
we got it coming we got Red Queen coming
on here so we got an awesome guest we
got to meet her at Guardian Con if you
guys didn't hear previously she was
awesome ultra nice we were probably
gonna talk ears off next week so
Oh real quick let's put scream on a spot
Guardian car next year sir what's happen
scream I'm gonna try to make it home all
bro
I'm gonna try to make it I can't make
commitments I have commitment issues I
was actually in Montreal for July 4th
and I had totally forgotten that we were
going away for that we had made those
plans maybe I don't know six months ago
with some other friends and I kind of
forgotten about it and but it was I was
trying to kind of work it out where my
my mother-in-law lives in Florida Oh
trying to figure out like you know like
make it work that trip but I guess we
were actually going down there in like
the fall so it just it was a weird
timing but the dates have been announced
already the tickets are up sir oh I
actually didn't see that when when it is
let's give him that information come
because I'm glad to hear precious cream
now live from the fans so you heard it
here first fans said he's considering
III you can get your premiere erasmus+
mmm the biggest con it's the 20 June 27
to 28 oh I can do that that's easier
that's easier yeah we go that's easy
acts of it let's get it is back at Rosen
Sugar Creek so the big thing that you're
gonna want to do if you guys are
interested in Guardian con is to follow
what are they called now by the way as I
say things and don't know what to say I
vent yes you're you don't want to follow
them for sure because they're gonna be
the ones that tell you when the hotel
vote blocks go on sale that's an
important piece because what we were at
the hotel we were the hotel Rosen
Shingle Creek samay zhing it's all there
you don't have to leave oh so and the
deal that you're able to get is
beautiful was absolutely bonkers so if
they get a nice deal in the hotel room
blocks that they did through Guardian
con it's awesome so yeah keep an eye out
for those as well so yeah plan for next
year I have no idea yeah I was like I
definitely feel I was missing I I got it
was great to see all the
everybody though together is like it's
like it's like a we talk with each other
so man I've seen this man in four years
you don't say like long time it was it
was dope it was old man like it was just
like its core specially if you got the
passion with destiny and I even tell
people who don't like dancing it's other
stuff for you man it was war and it's
boiling this whole arcade they got a
couple of videos up but it's as a
destiny content creator Lord Williams me
to be there you oh yeah you always want
I was like protein and I saw him yeah
pretty much a lot of people on Twitter
were like I got to turn it off man I'm
sad I didn't go like and I hadn't been
in 48 like three years I've missed mini
so I was like getting back it was the
right time to go back it was a great one
and Rosen Shingle is awesome the resort
is really really really really awesome
so yeah watch for those hotel blocks as
well but I think that is about all we
got
yep scream we was trying time this but
with audio delays it's interesting but
basically I'm gonna try and wrap it up
so I was trying to it has been and then
all together we say the last word so I
was trying for you guys to start but
it's like I'll say it has been and then
all together we're trying to get the
last words out but it's always kind of a
mess but it's always fun so well thank
you guys all for tuning in and chat this
is episode 66 climbing up there for July
19th and for everybody here live in in
chat it has been the last